please go ahead thank you okay thank you
so
be so being 102 I'll open up the hearing
on House Bill
1716 and prior to that I'll read a uh
script that I need to read as chair of
the house child and F children and
family law committee I find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
puru pursuant to ex executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically please note that there is
no physical location to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order I am
confirming that we are providing public
access to a meeting by telephone with
additional access possibilities by video
or other electronic means we are
utilizing Zoom for this electronic
meeting all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporar asly
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
address
https
colb zoom.
usj Back
418251 of the following phone numbers 1
6099 or 1
301 715 8592
providing public notice of the necessary
information for assessing the meeting
for accessing the meeting we previously
gave notice to the public of the
necessary information for accessing the
meeting including how to access the
meeting using Zoom or t
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar providing
a mechanism for the public to alert the
public body during a meeting if there
are problems with access if anybody has
27136 or email at
HCS at
leg.
s.n. us adjourning the meeting if the
public is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled um I want to introduce the
staff that are on in the meeting
assistant us uh chis Christina DWI Dyer
is the house committee
researcher uh is the meeting host
additional additional house committee
service staff providing support are Brad
Greenland Jen 4 and Pam
smling this is a public hearing on House
Bill 17116 to be followed by a public
hearing on Senate Bill
295 a copy of each bill has been posted
on the main page of the general court
website under The Heading remote
meetings please note that all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by roll call
vote uh we'll start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
memb when each member State their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which was required under
the right to no law um so I'll I'll ask
the uh actually prior to that uh if
there's any if there's any member of the
public wishing to testify uh they would
need to register using
HCS at l.st state. n. us and if you
could include your name and phone number
thank you and I'll ask the uh clerk
representative Conners to call uh roll
call the attendance please thank you
present and
Mulligan I'm present I'm in my home uh
I'm alone in the living room but there
is someone in my dining room who was
working on my
laptop thank you representative Connors
is here in my office alone
representative
Corson I'm here home
again okay your audio does not appear to
be your audio does not appear to be
working can you signal us with a thumbs
up that you're here that you can hear
me okay thank you representative French
I'm here alone
representative
grman hi everyone I'm here my family's
in the rest of the house I'm alone in
this room thank you representative
LC I am here alone in the spare room
representative patrino hi I am here in
my home office and I am
alone representative
Weber I I'm at my residence in Walpole
and I am
alone representative wiir here hi
everyone I am home in my kitchen
currently I'm alone I will have my kid
join me
later representative D
Simone hi good afternoon everyone I am
here in Atkinson in my sun room and I am
alone thank you representative
rice hi everybody I'm H in Hudson with I
have two kids at
home representative horn
good afternoon I am alone in my house in
Franklin sorry I'm alone room in
Franklin but my wife is also in the
house thank you representative
camarota I am present hello everyone um
I'm alone in my home but I have a new
puppy so I'm GNA mute myself when when
Fowler I don't see representative Fowler
here representative jurus I'm present in
my home in Meredith by myself thank you
representative
yella I am present and home alone thank
panace I am home in Amhurst I am alone
thank you and chairman
long I am present in Manchester and
alone thank you that completes the role
okay thank you uh representative Connors
uh at this time I'd uh like to call
Representative uh balero to introduce uh
house bill um
1760 um thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record representative Al
baldasaro Rock atam County District Five
London Derry and I'm also at home in my
office and my wife in and out of
here I I have brought this bill HB 1716
forward because recently I have received
many phone calls now I'm going to bring
you to a little bit of History prior in
2017 I introduced a bill uh on behalf of
a couple of veterans thinking this was
an issue in New
Hampshire um the Supreme Court Justice
in um
their um what do you call them their
lobbyist was that at the hearing and he
said we don't do this in New Hampshire
there's not a problem which I agreed
because I myself went to a divorce I
myself would collect disability I myself
brought forward the federal law under
im-
98-03 in my divorce and they did not use
my uh disability but I also got custody
of my child children at the time so
there was totally different case for me
but the I can't remember his name there
that uh in the Judiciary Committee that
said that the courts were not doing this
and then all of a sudden within the last
what just prior to me filing the late
entry of this legislation was I was
started getting phone calls from
veterans
homeless okay our veterans with issues
there that they were using the
disability
for child support or for alimony now I
want to please make this important
veterans do not want to get away from
paying child support that's not the
problem that they pay child support uh
they you know make sure you know many of
them we might have a one or two I don't
know but for the most part we you know
like to take care of our
responsibilities but in this case here
the veterans money the judges were not
going in accordance with the IM
98-03 and I sent you all a copy of this
here which goes into the apportionment
special
apportionment okay where it talks about
how the garisman to arrange for a
garnishment you know for child support
must go or should go to the
VA we have some judges have been
deciding writing that they don't need to
do this the Supreme Court there was a
case that went forward just recently
which the Supreme Court did not use the
IM
98-03 and Shan brunstein will testify on
what happened in that Supreme Court
decision
now the information that I submitted to
you was on different veterans that you
you're going to be able to see what's
going on this is called in homelessness
here and pro possibly suicide within the
veteran Community okay because when you
take away El this everything they
make now you got problems because some
of these veterans have issues mental
issue pts issue PTSD issues um and like
I said it's causing a huge problem
within the veterans community the VA has
identified this throughout the country
and this is why you know they came out
of
1998 uh which was published there by the
uh for the IM
98-03 to correct this problem okay uh to
their rules and laws um but if you read
it there's a process where the children
can get you know support but it must go
to the VA for them to make the decision
now why did they do that because when
you get disability you're 100% there's a
certain amount of Mone money that you
get extra because you have children and
I agree 100% that that money belongs to
the children to take care of the kids
not one veteran should be excused from
supporting their children and I don't
know any veteran that don't not don't
support their children because the many
that I talk to you know are involved in
their children's life but some of them
been pushed away for financial
reasons um
if you look under the child support law
and we added this into the bill to make
a change under the section c i put in we
put in the law the the uh federal law
okay that you know New Hampshire should
be complying with my understanding of
the courts is our law was silent on this
here and the judges could do this this
is why we're pushing because not all
veterans know the federal law like I do
when I went to court and brought it to
the judge and I thought the judge was
very Prof did a great job and he
complied with the federal law because
there was nothing really in state
law okay the formula needs to be fixed
on this here because this disability
like myself I probably spend $2 $300
more a month on over the count of
medication that I need that I'm required
you know to get that the VA don't issue
me that I purchase from s you know for
chess and other things I won't get into
that but and I can see other veterans
probably having the same issues that I
have that that need to this extra money
but when you take away a lot of their
money and you add in their dollars into
the formula the ones who make out on
this here is the courts because under
title 4D when they collect money to the
courts the federal kicks in money okay
to this so when you look at the bill uh
and I don't have it in front of me as
far as the fiscal note but I heard
there's a heavy fiscal note what that is
is the Court's not going to get that
money from the federal government
because they're not taking advantage and
collecting the money from the veterans
okay they're not adding in their
disability so this is something that we
need to look at and make sure and push
that aside and say the court should be
making money off of the veterans
disability that's being added into the
formula now I won't go on because you're
going to have quite a few other veterans
they're going to testify on this here
but in closing I want to just make sure
that we understand the veteran Community
is not trying to get out of being you
know supporting their children they're
just trying to get out of being homeless
because they're taking a lot of that
money away from them and they can't
afford to live and you got some that are
living I think in DOA or in other areas
out of their cars here in the state of
New Hampshire okay because of what's
going on and I didn't know this until
recently when I went and said wow this
is something that needs to be brought
forward you know that we fix and every
legislation that I put forward to is
normally nonpartisan my good friend
representative Linda massam Miller was
supposed to be on this here but because
of the quickness and then what happened
with the virus she never got a chance to
sign on okay so I wanted to make this a
nonpartisan bill which like every other
bill I submitted throughout my 14 years
I've always put Democrats and
Republicans on the bill but that's the
reason why there's only a couple of
sponsors on there and that's all I have
thank you
representative uh any Committee Member
have a question and I see representative
horn I Christina are you controlling the
mute yes and sometimes I it's you
getting a pro there we go okay okay
representative horn thank you for your
testimony representative baldasaro
um I just have a a
question how are these veterans not
employed who are seeking to support
their children uh could you expand on
what's preventing these veterans from
getting gainful employment well you have
some that are 100% disabled uh even
though some of the 100% do work and that
money is included it's not that they're
not support them okay but you have some
that can't work some would you know on
mental issues they're involved with the
vet center involved in and out of the
VA I mean you got to I mean I you I can
only use me like an example every six
months I go into the VA and get blood
every I every other couple of months I
go get a sh my spine you know what I
mean so on different medical issues that
I have so I can imagine a veteran with
PTSD you know it's hard for them to hold
a job but they do get the you know some
on their retirement the ones that were
put out get a not only a ba disability
but they also get a
retirement so followup representative
horn thank you Mr chairman
so when these
veterans uh made the decision to have
kids and bring kids into the world they
may not have had these disabilities and
since having had the children they
suffered uh an injury or qualifier
disability after the child's been born
this isn't a decision to neglect their
child it's a decision influenced by the
injuries they're sustained you know
that's a great question here
representative I appreciate that because
you're right nobody I went into the
morning cor healthy never did it in a
million years that I expect to have
gallbladder out kit you know and all
this two bits of cancer and from you
know and medication issues and other
stuff so yeah this happens for their
service in the military and throughout
the years
you know it gets worse you know on on
the veterans and it's a shame you know I
think we owe it to make damn well sure
that not one veteran is Left Behind in
this state of New Hampshire at the same
Baran thank you uh thank you
representative baldasaro uh for bringing
this to our attention um I
um the CH children family law had before
it House Bill
362 uh which uh has been sent for
interim study at the present time and it
has to do with issues related to child
support and this was done in Rel in uh
um uh in concert with a study done by
UNH on child support which is required
by law every four years years for us to
review this so my question to you is if
if you are you aware it's a two-part
question are you aware of the fact that
that there is this ongoing review at the
present time and if so is there some
particular urgency that we respond to
that we vote on this particular piece of
legislation um at in in this year uh yes
there is and the reason is because it's
forcing veterans to be homeless it's
forcing you know suicide and other
things that are going on in the state of
New Hampshire um HB 362 I'm the ranking
member of the Veterans Affairs former
chair Vice chair I've been on that
committee for 14 years I haven't been
invited to that to speak on behalf of
the veterans we've got a great chairman
uh Trish and uh I don't even know if she
even been invited to have a stay on that
committee uh that deals with another
part of child support in dealing with
the formula the veteran Community the
that very good uh I have representative
uh
pacity did I say his name
right panace peni thank you you had your
muted Dyer is could you take him off
mute yeah um is there a prompt for you
uh representative panace that allows you
to come off mute there
is it wasn't allowing me to do that
thank you Mr Speaker in full disclosure
I'd like to say that I'm retired
military so I understand um what the
representative ballero is talking about
but a question to Mr
representative
baleros uh the disability money that a
veteran receives can you explain where
that money comes from and what and is
that money a part of uh or a certain
percentage of the individuals
pay oh um the the money comes from the
VA on there in
the is issued on a monthly basis the
first of the month to every uh disabled
veteran anywhere deping if you're 10% 20
30 all the way up to 100% so this just
not based upon excuse me it's based on
the service members uh rate and rank
correct uh no the disability has nothing
to do with rank or service uh how many
years the retirement deals with uh Rank
and this you know service of years the
disabilities of total apples and oranges
from retirement to dis disability so if
you were injured in the military and you
were put out of a medical discharge they
retired you more than likely okay
especially during time of war and then
your disability is a separate fund that
comes from the VA to help the veteran
live and
survive okay so
now but correct me if follow up Mr Mr
chairman follow sure correct me if I'm
wrong though Al is it is it based upon
um the individuals if if he if he's a
master sergeant or if he's a just a
Corporal is it the same amount of money
disability is the same it goes by what
your percentage is if you're 10% 20 all
the way up to a 100 so this is dealing
with veterans that could be 10 20% could
be 30 all the way up to
100% it has nothing to do with your rank
if that's then they would double mine as
an e with 20 you know two years in the
Marines very good uh I don't see any
other questions are there any other
questions I don't see any so uh thank
you representative oh wait a minute I
got a uh question from uh representative
uh
patrio
patrino thank you thank you Mr chairman
and thank you uh representative for
taking my question I actually don't know
the answer to this so maybe you can give
me a little clarification I'm taking a
look at Social Security Disability uh uh
payments and uh that those are garnished
for child support uh what would be the
difference in this regard uh concerning
veterans disability the difference here
is on the veterans disability is first
of all a veteran that's getting 100%
disabled can collect Social Security
Disability also we're not going after
that that money should be in there you
know even though it's not a marital
asset by the law it is a part of use for
child support we're not touching that
the veteran disability is designed a
veteran to be able to live and be able
to pay for any other stuff their
medication above and beyond that you use
like me you know I mean uh so there's a
big difference there like I said once
again apples and oranges on this the
federal government came out with a law
on you know the disability for veterans
didn't did I hope I answered your
question and if there's anything else I
want to thank you all for taking the
time on hearing this very important you
know issue facing our veterans uh in New
Hampshire it looks like representative
rice has a a
question yeah representative rice I I
I'm having a hard time unmuting myself
so oh you can stay unmuted that will be
fine I got phones ringing and all that
so I see
sure representative rice who is
muted okay I was
trying um so
representative B DeSaro
um so this is already a federal law this
is going to put the state in compliance
with federal law is that correct that is
correct and followup Mr chairman
followup sure so by putting us in
compliance with federal law we should
not be hearing any more complaints from
the um courts saying from me people who
have been to the courts saying that this
has happened right no you are 100% right
this should be corrected the courts uh
will comply with the law you know of New
Hampshire you know and you know because
if it's in federal law we should be in
New Hampshire law and one more followup
Mr chairman followup sure does it do a
child's um a child's relationship with
their parent any justice to have that
parent
homeless because we are taking any of
their in what little income they may
have to um live with well you know
that's a good great question there
because you you push it pushes the vet
away that they've got to you know
they're out in the street or they're you
know doing everything they can to
survive they don't want their children
to see them like that I mean I know some
homeless veterans there that are hurting
and they don't you know they don't even
go around their children because of the
fact of they can't afford to get their
own apartment or there's not enough bed
space in the state of New Hampshire for
the homeless veterans but then again we
have some that don't want to come out of
the woods because we do count every year
you know so I I just think you know New
Hampshire should be where we don't leave
one veteran behind and we have a large
large population here in the state of
New Hampshire of veterans about 110
State
yulla yes thank you chair Mr chairman
thank you uh for taking my question my
question is regarding uh the constit the
Supreme Court
uh judgment earlier this year saying
that um our current law is not in
conflict with the federal law and
how um you see that there's maybe more
information that the that the Supreme
Court didn't look at or if you have that
information or you know of someone
that's going to testify regarding that
issue in the
future um yes I I sent you the what the
Supreme Court Court didn't look at under
the im-
98-03 okay in the Supreme Court you know
I'm I got the utmost confidence in our
Supreme Court on what they do but I
think they was failed to utilize the
federal law in their decision and I do
have Sean brunstein who will be
testifying who is the case and he he
will bring that up along with other
veterans okay thank you okay uh yeah one
one question I have representative
baldasaro there's there's a there's a
program called aid and
attendance um which which helps veterans
uh with um living quarters uh with homes
with rents uh in other you know food and
what have you um so if if I could hear
from the homeless veterans whether they
applied for that and and either got
denied or uh sold
you know my understanding is that uh
there are programs out there for
homeless veterans uh with respect to
housing uh subsidies um so are you aware
of the uh Aid in attendance
with I've never heard of this Mr
chairman I never heard of the called Aid
in attendance I know we the um veterans
count I know that we have the Liberty
house I know that we have Nashua I know
that we have you know homeless shelter
there homel shelter in plym homeless
shelter for families in
Manchester um you know what I'm saying
but there is a program out of
Massachusetts and I can't think of the
name and I don't think it's Aiden
attendance and
um um that is moving into Manchester
okay corre I'm aware of that yeah it's a
federal uh it's actually it's a national
company yes but they are not up and
running yet no they're not no you know
what I'm saying so I am that program
that's goinging in you know they brought
that up to the state veterans advisory
committee which I have a meeting tonight
at five o'clock on okay yeah I just got
that off the uh benefits va.gov website
yeah I didn't know it was called a and
attendance is another name they use to
the federal grants they get and it's a
great program once they get set up in
Manchester very good uh representative D
Simone
hi thank you um Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question representative
baldasaro in listening to the discussion
we talked about or you talked about um
veterans who are in
shelters um which quite frankly I think
is a shame um do you think that if this
bill were to pass it would free up some
of the income for those
and give them the opportunity to join in
on some of the other
um like uh some of the other things like
uh representative long spoke about so
they could get their own apartment I
can't imagine a a veteran who is a proud
man or woman having to have their child
come to a homeless shelter to visit them
I just can't imagine what that would do
to their psychiatric
uh
Health you know agree with you 100% it's
an embarrassment you know I mean and
it's a mental thing on the veteran also
you know thinking that I can't go around
my children and them see me like this
here right you know it's a shame that
these guys some of these veterans serve
two three times Iraq Afghanistan you
know I'm a desert St veteran myself you
know and um you know it's it's a mental
thing there when you you know you in
these positions here because you went in
the military successful you went in the
military to die for your country and to
come home and see that you're not
getting the support is is a shame but I
can't remember who brought up the Social
Security that was a great question
because that Social Security they get if
you're a disabled vet you're getting
that also and they're taking that money
support thank you represent
here can I have a followup you can thank
you just just a comment representative
baldasaro I remember um many of my dad
who was a World War II veteran many of
his friends lived in the city that I
lived in in Malden Mass in h a place
called the projects and those projects
were built for returning veterans who
were many of them were um disabled and
they lived in beautiful homes with their
families and I just think it's a shame
that every state in the country doesn't
do the same thing now for current coming
current veterans who are coming home
well you know what you just brought up I
my father was a Korean War veteran if
you're familiar with Cambridge
Massachusetts I lived in rooseville
Towers it was for veterans there was the
projects we lived there first cup few
years five years or whatever until my
father was able to buy a home and we
moved you know up the street so yeah no
that that used to be that way of course
those homes now have been transferred
over to you know in low income and other
stuff there they're no longer just
veterans right very good and I see uh
representative
Connors thank you thank you for taking
my question representative I'm not too
familiar with the the disability formula
does it take into account the number of
children that a veteran has in the
calculation of their disability payment
yes it does if you have one children two
three four it adds up on how many
children you have and that money
rightfully the certain portion belongs
to the children and that's why the VA uh
came up with this law okay to make sure
that your Worman goes to them and they
authorize that money to go from the
finance center right to the family okay
that that money belongs to the children
but now New Hampshire is going around
the system and not using it because they
get more money under title 4D by
collecting it
themselves thank you very much okay see
you no more questions uh representative
bisaro thank you for your testimony
thank you Mr chair in
committee and
available uh Miss Dyer is he on we can't
hear you you're muted yep he is uh right
here I've just promoted him just a
moment and he'll be right
on aha there he is okay thank you very
much Mr chair so um I'm uh pleased to be
the uh pleased to be the second panelist
on a virtual house meeting and very very
tough act to follow I'm um I was
represent baldasar and represented
baldasaro is very eloquent as usual and
I certainly uh was glad the underline
that veterans want to support their
children and certainly nobody believes
otherwise I'm not a veteran myself but U
my father is a veteran my father my
uncle's a World War II veteran many
other relatives are veterans including
although he was about 140 years older
than me General Grant The Man Who U so
representative hardigan do do you have
testimony with reference to house 176
absolutely yes absolutely and um so and
I sent in some written testimony um
which hopefully we Reed that okay so
child support payments for the benefit
of the children even though they're
typically paid by a non-custodial parent
to custodial parent and that usually
happens um after the relationship
between the two partners has fallen
apart and there's often a lot of
resentment between the the co-parents
and of course often the children don't
feel good about it but anyway regardless
of how you feel about it you're morally
and legally obligated to look after your
children um even if you're not in good
terms with your ex and then I guess that
applies even if you're a disabled
veteran as the r baldasaro AG age
um and um just by the way I I'm on the
Judiciary Committee I'm speaking only
for myself and I think I didn't formerly
introduce myself froment Timothy Oregan
from straford County District Six towns
of Durham and Madbury and um they anyway
and um actually I actually don't
remember the Judiciary Committee hearing
Rend baldasaro referred to although he
is a frequent visitor to our committee
anyway so veterans disability payments
are not just for veterans themselves the
veterans fam is integral part of the
program and um if you're more than 30%
disabled you get extra payments based if
you have a spouse or dependent child and
when the eligible disabled veteran dies
their children receive payments until
the age of 18 or 23 after till in school
and the surviving spouse in many cases
also is eligible for veterans I think
sometimes even if they're divorced but
they've been married to the veteran and
then parents can get veterans so this is
a program which supports the entire
family which makes sense because one
family member's disability affects the
whole family so excluding the benefits
from State child support calculations
flies in the face of how the veterans
disability payments program is designed
um also as the fiscal note passes and I
actually have the bill in the fiscal
note in front of me and I've been
looking at it while listening to Res
bisaro um families will be for forced to
seek more aid from State assistant
programs hence for the from the uh and
from the taxpayers it's also possible
the state will be denied a significant
amount of Federal funding since this
bill is in conflict with current federal
law um 45 CFR paragraph
33256 states that the state of New
Hampshire child support guidelines must
considered all earnings or income of the
non-custodial parents so that mean
phrase all earnings and incomes means
all earnings and income that includes
the veterans disability benefits even
though they're not subject to the
federal income tax and um so that's a so
so I just think this bill is uh and also
this bill is unnecessary there's no
pressing need for it
um even though uh well I guess I guess I
won't make a comment about what's going
on with the uh military possibly being
uh used domestically but which will
cause a lot more PTSD if that happens
because um anyway I think this bill is
unnecessary certainly unnecessary at
this time and unnecessary at any time so
I urge you to uh find it in expedient
legisl so thanks be happy representative
Oregon any uh questions for
representative
Oregon and I don't see any thank you
representa of Oregon thanks it's been
fun to be part of History thank you for
having me so uh Chris Christina I I
don't have any other reps on the list to
testify could you just confirm that
before I start going to the public
that's correct I do not have any others
okay great uh thank you so I I I have a
LIF uh list representative Conor's do
you have that same list that's what I'll
be going by it was emailed to to
us
[Music]
um so uh next list representative
baldasaro I have the list from
representative baldasaro I don't have
one from the um speak HCS I believe
there was one from HS uh Christina Well
I did email it directly to you oh you to
me not no I I included her as well but
I'll I'll email it right now wor okay
everby and I do not see her in the list
um if she is in attendance we would ask
that you press star nine which will
raise your hand and move you to the top
of the
list we did check and did not see the
number or a name matching that so she
may not be here
okay um I'll next I'll call uh Nicholas
raldi
is is uh Nicholas
uh I do not see Nicholas raldi okay and
for the record uh representative fer is
here I I did see him uh representative
list and she
comes hi can you hear me
yes okay um my name is Mora Ryan I live
in legendary New Hampshire um I am a
veteran a combat veteran um and I was
asked to speak on behalf of female
veterans who are custodial parents um in
reference to IM 98-03 I just wanted to
say that's not a law or mandate the
apportionment process was meant to buoy
the state process because the federal
government is not allowed to intervene
and divorce per the supremacy clause
um so I don't feel like this is
something that's necessary and I also
feel that it's detrimental to children
and I'm going to explain why um I'm a
single parent I have a son with
disabilities my son has
autism um I met my ex-husband when I was
a Corporal and he was a sergeant in the
Army um and he was making about $1,200 a
month and I was making about $800 a
month and ultimately we divorced because
my son uh has disabilities and he
requires quite a bit of care
subsequently after getting out of the
military he was rated 100% permanent in
total and he gets a total of almost
$4,000 from the Department of Veterans
Affairs so with a $4,000 income he is
able to live without working because he
can live on $4,000 and just so you know
if a veteran is 100% disabled they are
going to get over $3,000 a month so if
they are homeless I don't know where
they're spending their money but there
are apartments that are certainly less
than3 $200 a month um the apportionment
process is a very long process as I said
it's meant to buoy the state process I
actually filed for my apportionment with
my ex because his VA disability is his
sole source of income in 2011 when my
son was seven years old my son is now 16
and I have not received one penny of
child support from that entire period of
time um in addition to that he's
required to provide health insurance for
my son which he has not done and he gets
champ VA which is provided to him free
by the government
um the state is the one that's supposed
to drive the process for divorce so the
state is supposed to look as
representative Horgan said at all forms
of income including VA disability to
determine the proper amount of child
support now in the state process when we
went to court there were things like
Discovery and discussions about um our
finances because I am also a VA dis
disabled veteran I'm at 90% so I get
about $2,000 a month to support my son
um and I can't work because I have
migraines that induce blindness but
that's a whole other thing um so the
state looked our incomes and made
decision that he was to pay me $330 a
month based off his army um income I've
never gotten a subsequent increase and
I've never asked for one because I
figured if he just gave me the $330 a
month we could call it Square um the a
portioning process is not favorable to
the custodial p because they're denied
the opportunity for Discovery they're
not allowed to see what the other party
submits and subsequently they're not
able to refute any information um and
it's it's generally not a fair process I
mean I've been waiting almost 10 years
just to get a hearing to get my
apportionment heard and because ofs are
secondary claims to VA benefits claims
they get pushed down list further and
further I don't know how many of you are
familiar with Gody versus Wii it was a
court case which was filed against the
VA because of the long amount of time
that veterans have to wait for claims to
be resolved um in Gody all the cases
that filed on behalf of those veterans
who are filing for VA benefits got moved
ahead of all the people who were waiting
for their aborate cases to be heard um
this federal government has essentially
stated that all forms of income are
required to supply child support and
under 38 CFR 3501
um child support is one of the things
that is Exempted so in other words 38
CFR uh five
35531 I'm sorry I'm not quoting exactly
and I know someone else s in the legal
jargon and I'm not a specialist at that
but it exempts VA benefits from ordinary
creditors meaning bill collectors but
because that money is supplied for the
family it's hold into the family I mean
we're talking about veterans who are out
there who are not paying child support
and leaving their female veteran partner
at a dis disadvantage in the system now
there are some people who say well the
basic needs will be met because the kid
can go on Medicaid and the kid can be on
Wick well Wick only lasts up until age
five what happens after that why should
the taxpayer pay for Medicaid if if the
dependent should be getting it through
champ VA um why should the taxpayer have
to pay for those things if those other
things are in place already now in my
case my ex is getting ch VA but he
refuses to allow my son to be under him
so I've paid for insurance for him I've
paid for ortha J for him for to the tune
of $10,000 because he's a kid who has
disabilities I have a lot of expenses
for him I paid for every penny of his
insurance even though the court said
that he was required to cover it um now
the VA disability is his sole source of
income he's getting almost $4,000 he can
live off that um I've applied to child
support enforcement through the state of
New Hampshire roxan Bryce was my case
worker um she knows that I've been
trying to get the payments that
particularly now with covid-19 I need
them because my son requires a tutor
with uh remote learning because he can't
handle it um and she would not enforce
that and the HHS I've had emails from
them stating they would not enforce so
I'm over rears of almost $30,000 on a
$330 a month child
appointment um
my ex-husband has a farm he has a
$40,000 truck and I don't wish ill
against him for that I'm grateful that
he's able to have things in the world
and he's doing well but my son has to
go and eat out of the free food line and
free and reduced lunch and why should he
have to do that because if I got that
$330 a month I could be able to support
him with other things if I got that
insurance coverage for him I would be
able to support him for other
things um as I've stated I've been
waiting for hearing for almost 10 years
my hearing was scheduled for April 15 20
uh 2020 and it was canceled because of
covid-19 which is going to set it back
over a year um I'm still waiting for
resolution um as I said the
apportionment process hinges on the
state process including VA disability in
it because the federal government under
the supremacy clause cannot determine
amounts of Child Support um because they
can't interfere in State's rights and
divorce and child support is considered
state right so the way it works is under
the apportionment claim you apply for it
and they look at number one whether or
not the child is is residing with the
non-custodial parent if they're residing
with the non-custodial parent it doesn't
apply and number two if that person is
reasonably discharging their duty to
support their child they base that
information on the court ordered child
support So if you take this out
then there would be no ability to
determine if the the N uh the
non-custodial parent were paying their
child support because it is based on the
state
determination um the rules for the
apportionment are very they're
unregulated they're very subjective and
they're not clearly defined they
actually rely on the state to try and
clearly Define those um I can tell you
that my ex was able to get an attorney
to defend him through the VFW I was told
that I was not entitled to an attorney
even though I'm a veteran because um I
am the one who is filing for the
abortion me claim
um I just want to make clear that there
are many other female veterans like me
who don't get a lot to live off of who
are not able to uh not able to get our
child support payments because our exes
are living off via disability um I do
know that federal law states that if you
exceed $5,000 in two years of child
support payments it's a federal crime
per uh punishable by law now my next
step if I can't get an enforcement
hearing is to go through that process
but I don't want to go through that
process because from my perspective it's
counterproductive I don't want my ex to
have to go to prison to make him pay
child support it doesn't benefit me it
doesn't benefit him all I want to get is
the $330 a month um I mean he is
remarried now so he's also able to live
off his spouse's income I don't have
another spouse I'm not able to live off
any additional income and that income is
not considered in my son's divorce and
it shouldn't be because she makes her
own money but he does have the benefit
of that which the VA also did not
consider um so I hope you have questions
for me because I'm I do know this
process very well I do know that the
state process is fair just because due
process is sort of observed where it's
really not the aborate claim um I don't
want to kids staying in poverty because
their veteran parents can't collect
um I do know also I do know that Mr
bronstein is probably going to testify
that many parents are agreeable to
co-parenting that has not been my
experience um it is divorce is kind of a
vicious process but children should not
be a part of that they should be
supported by both parents and it should
be Equitable and you have to remember
that if that female veteran who's
applying for those child support
payments if they're living on the street
that's also not fair
um I don't think that this should be
supported because as I stated IM
9803 is just a memo and it's actually a
list of options presented by the federal
government to avoid criminal prostiution
for veterans with disabilities it's an
option for the parent to apply for the
apportionment claim the state does not
do it um I've been dealing with that for
over 10 years I am also a veteran um and
I I would really sort of ask why would
it be that if I'm a veteran I'm trying
to get my child support payment when I
get less money than he does that my
consideration is less so or my child's
consideration is less because really
alimony and stuff between spouses
spouses can fend for themselves kids
cannot and kids need to be taken care of
and kids deserve that um so I guess
that's kind of it I hope you have
questions for me because I'm very
familiar with this process very good
thank thank you Miss Ryan um we do have
horn thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
um somebody told me that um
the dependence factor into the
disability uh calculation and I was
wondering if you could confirm that for
me so that even if you're 90 if you are
90% disabled you get a payment if you
are 90% disabled with kids um your
payment would be larger could you help
me with that yes I can confirm that the
actual payment for a spouse is higher
than anything else because I think for a
spouse you get I don't know the exact
amount and I'd have to look it up but
it's it's a it's possibly $200
um for your first child it can be around
$100 but it decreases with each child um
in this case my son is his third child
son follow up uh representative horn
grman thank you chairman
long and thank you Mora Ryan for coming
to testify before
us um thank you for having me thank you
for your service as well and I'm a mom
to a 15-year-old with autism so I know
what life is can look
like needing a lot of support um I just
have a I have a question regarding um
enforcement of the benefits the medical
benefits are there any consequences or
ways of enforcement you've said that you
have haven't received those
payments
but are there any consequences in the
system or does it just keep on spiraling
of not so in your divorce decree it
states that he should be um providing
the medical uh Insurance yes a
consequence for not doing that the only
way for me to enforce that is for me to
try and get a contempt order and TR at
this at this time he's over two years in
$5,000 so I could pursue a Federal
Criminal prosecution which would put him
in prison but as I said I see that as
counterproductive to our interest
because I would like him to pay the
child support but I don't necessarily
want him to go to prison to do it so
that's the
only option there are no
ways places along the way to get
enforcement he has voluntary voluntary
options of enforcement but he has not
taken them and I think that speaks
loudly anybody who's dealt with family
law knows that co-parenting is difficult
and it doesn't really work the way we
think it will obviously because the
police station is the drop off and
pickup point for a lot of people it
co-parenting is difficult for many
people and in our like in in his case he
could apply for Social Security
disability he chooses not to and I have
no way of forcing him to do it and I
wish he would because at least I would
get
something thank you representative
dmon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and also thank
you for your service thank you I
appreciate
that I'm just curious uh you said that
uh you're using State Medicaid for your
child I am not I actually pay for heal
insurance for my
son you don't you use a champus which is
uh utilized by most
veterans I do not have that um my ex has
that and you can't get that as a veteran
I am not able to because they strictly
enforc pii which means that in order for
my son to get the champ VA or champus he
would have to sign off on it and I have
never been able to get him to sign off
on
it okay thank
you uh any further
questions seeing none uh thank you Ryan
thank
you uh next I have
Church Christina is Devon Church on uh
I'm looking I don't see it uh donon
church if you're on could you please
n okay don't see any anyone moving on
brunstein is I is Mr BR here it comes
you're now able to talk Mr
bronstein thank you I'm
go uh good afternoon uh family committee
um thank you very much for having me
today um thank you Miss Ryan for also
your testimony today I appreciate U what
you've said um I do have a couple of um
additional points to what Miss Ryan said
um she's a very unique situation because
she is dual mil military with the chap
VA um can petition the VA to send in
with a copy of the child's birth
certificate and show that the other
veteran is 100% And they will
automatically put her put the child on
um I've gone through this with a few
other veterans um unfortunately there
are certain situations with every
veteran that make the cases unique um
with my current case um which I'm sure
some of you have seen at the New
Hampshire Supreme Court um the biggest
issue that I ran into was asking for due
process through the im9
9803 um I asserted my rights through due
process for the 14th Amendment of the US
Constitution as well as the 14th article
and 15 article of the New Hampshire Bill
of Rights um I was denied this process
specifically stating that the family
courts are to adhere to the um New
Hampshire RSA 458 C5 um and that was
directly um outlined in my divorce which
is why my case went up to the New
Hampshire supreme court because they had
overstepped the IM 9803 which is the
apportionment process for disabled
veterans who may be on Social Security
which I am a little background on me um
I was in the military under five years
um I was discharged medically um when I
went in I was physically and mentally
fit I came out um and I basically was
broken um since then I also worked for
the federal service um I was retired
under OPM dis retirement through the
federal service um since then I've had
26 surgeries due to my military injuries
um I've also not been able to contain a
stable job despite what my background is
um based on that I went through the
processes I needed to with the VA I had
to go through many hurdles as some may
know of how they work and despite that I
was able to come out 100% permanent in
total back dated to when I got off of
active duty back in 200
seven um I went through a divorce it was
very contentious um there is no doubt
about that um but there's not a single
veteran that I know that's a parent that
doesn't want to help parent their child
including paying child support I 100%
believe that that is my child's I owe it
to them to give them every bit that I
can um my issues come from my income um
is disability 100% um through the feds
through the VA and through Social
Security um there were a couple of
points that were made today about the
review that UNH does um with Kristen
Smith that she did recently um I did
contact Miss Smith and U or Dr Smith and
they clearly stated that they did not
take any information taken into account
if somebody was a veteran so when the
court goes ahead and submits the child
support order to the state they're not
sure they're a vetan veteran so they're
not able to conduct the IM
9803 however uh Mary Beth odini who is a
supervisor over there as well as um
Jenny rhods who's also supervisor over
there in the title 4D office um I asked
them multiple times to start the process
of the IM 9803 which it clearly states
in section one on page two that the
state 4D office and the oblig are to
submit an ement request to the VA um I
was was told multiple times that they do
not do that and that they would enforce
to whatever degree they could up
including um sanctions and could cause
me to be in contempt with a court order
despite asking for a garnishment and
despite asking um for them to not
enforce because I was in an appeal
process um the state refused to do that
in fact they sent me letters stating I
was out of compliance and that they were
going to enforce orders um including
taking any anything that I may have
including my driver's license um on top
of that when they submitted um
the request from me to to show that I
was in an appeal they also dis discarded
that and stated that they were still
going to enforce and that I needed to
figure out how I was going to get the
additional funds um which as 100% uh
permanent total I am not able to work um
it's not that I choose not to work I
physically cannot um at this time
um I have my daughter UH 60 to 70% of
the time I was able to obtain uh 50 50
with my my ex-wife um but that on top of
includes um in my testimony that I've
provided you today on top of paying
child support I also was ordered to pay
Private health insurance which costs me
over $621 for myself in my child um I
also was told to pay child costs
including um the amount of money I spent
to have spent time with her
um and with that on top of Child Support
I'm I'm looking over, dollar a month um
again I'm not saying I shouldn't pay
child support I'm just asking that the
state go through the IM 9803 which was
given out back in 1998 from the August
1998 committee with the VA um down in um
Congress and
DC again with the due process rights
that I had requested I was denied at the
local Court I went to Supreme Court I
was also denied I went ahead and I filed
the Congressional um because I had asked
the VA what I could do and they said
since I was the veteran I could not ask
for it to be done that the state must uh
start the process I filed the
Congressional with Congress Pap's office
they did assist um the state still
refused to do the IM 9803 I went down to
Boston uh Regional um where the AFC
where the Mandate comes out of at the at
the second page you could see the
regional office information down there I
spoke with Miss relle Phillips who
contacted the state of New Hampshire
once she found out that the state was
not being in compliance with the IM
9803 and the state went ahead and
started the IM 9803 process what they
also did is they informed the oblige
that she was not required to participate
in the actual process which would be
looked at as obstruction of justice um
by not doing that that does not provide
me with due process because then the VA
cannot look at both Apples to Apples to
see what the child needs are um by doing
that was a detriment to myself I almost
lost my home I was in foreclosure for
nearly 24 months I went through the
Department of Veterans Affairs for
assistance I even went as far as
applying to section 8 housing I received
a letter back from section 8 that stated
there was a s to n year weight period
despite being an honorable and abled
veteran with that being said I went
through and I applied through the DHHS
for assistance for my child and for me
and despite me providing to them their
own um manual the
FMS FSM
SR5 um dated
0100 it does say that veterans benefits
are to be included as earned as unearned
income with the exception that benefits
specific speically designated as payment
for hospitalization or medical service
are excluded income um based on what my
injuries entail as also what
representative alal borsa um provided
with us I take medications and have to
be seen by outside providers because a
VA can't provide me what what I need um
those that amount goes over what my
child support um self- sustainment is so
right there I'm already in a hole um in
add addition to the um the aid in
attendance that somebody did mention on
here today the aid in attendance is for
specific disabled veterans um that need
to qualify for that and there is a
backlog to receive that you have to go
through a very
strenuous um clear um checks and
balances I guess you can put and there's
a lot of red tape I've applied for
almost every single program I can
qualify for and unfortunately I'm met
with a lot of denials it doesn't mean
that I don't want to help my child it
means that I'm trying everything I can
but I can't sustain my own life let
alone my child's if I can't live with
the amount of money that I have and my
legal well my legal bills themselves and
also my medical issues as they are there
is a program called HUD HUD Vash through
the VA that is assisting veterans um but
what they're finding is also that
they're actually taking including their
disability compensation for their child
support and it's Le the veteran literal
literally nothing um to even have for
food um we don't qualify for snap
because we're over income because of the
VA disability
benefits um there was another um report
out by the Department of Defense in May
2018 which I can provide to the board
where the May uh 2018 DOD report shows
that they do see that the disability
compensation does have a portion that is
aable for the family but they see that
those funds are to sustain for the
disability V the disabled veteran
because of the injuries they
sustain um based on the testimony today
that we heard from the fiscal note with
the um I think it was the fourth um I
forget I'm sorry I apologize um for the
note that's in there the regulation
under 45 CFR uh
459a um remuneration for employment is
based on if you received income from
that employment um since disability
compensation has nothing to do with the
time of service that you were in
including your rank or your pay is not
it is not included as income which is
why the IRS does not include it in your
taxes in addition the New Hampshire
judicial system when you are looking at
doing any type of civil procedures if
you look on the protected income list
you will see veterans disability
benefits and that reflects 38
5301a um
I ask that this board um approves this
and and listens to our testimony um and
if there's any questions I can answer
please let me
know thank you Mr bronstein uh
yella I thank you uh for for recognizing
me thank you for taking the question my
question is um in regards to
this uh state agency uh state Child
Support Enforcement office not f um
doing this uh apportionment request
review um can that uh I don't see that
this bill would address that issue and
has um I guess has that been fully
addressed now that the um that the state
agency or in or
this since the um
like the commissioner or their
representative from the VA contacted New
Hampshire is that now being handled
properly and so that's no longer an
issue or do we need to um really address
that in legislation or in some way um
making that state agency follow that
process and
um yes
so um thank you for your question um to
answer simp
um this what we've provided with just
adding the sub paragraph in sub
paragraph D essentially basically would
show that the courts when they're
looking to do child support that they
would need to motion the state to
initiate the apportionment process which
is listed under IM
9803 um from there it then goes to the
VA which assesses the situation as well
and comes back with the determination of
what the veteran can actually provide
through their compensation and then they
can go ahead and apportionment directly
to the custodial parent um if they deem
that it is
necessary um as far as is my situation
cleared no it is not I actually had to
file another Congressional this week and
I had to place a complaint into the
Civil Rights division um at the federal
health and human services based on the
non-compliance and the lack of due
process I'm receiving through the New
Hampshire state courts my specific C
case um did not include the IM 98 03
they also listed the wrong um Federal
quote um they actually the correct one
should be
3101 and they listed
1301 um which has to do with voke rehab
and not anything to do with my case so
the the court didn't even look at the
correct uh federal guidelines that I had
rsas thank
you are there any other members have a
up uh seeing n thank you Mr brunstein
thank
you next I'll call up uh John jet
Christina is uh Mr jet here we did
receive some Communications from him
test his testimony yes he is in the list
moment oh there he is okay perfect here
we
go okay Miss Mr
jet hi good afternoon
everybody all to the members of the
children and family law committee thank
you for inviting us uh in this
conference today uh my name is John
Thomas Jad I'm a 90% disabled veteran I
served uh 10 years and 10 months of
honorable US Air Force service a sure
from November 1998 and was medically
disability retired back in September
2009 uh for many years uh New
Hampshire's RSA title 43 uh Under The
Domestic Relations chapter 4 58c the
child support guidelines uh has
inappropriately mandated the assignment
or attachment of awarded uh disability
uh Department of Veterans Affairs
disability compensation benefits in all
child support
establishment and um I'm sorry yeah it's
child supports establishment and
enforcement proceedings in the state of
New Hampshire um as a result the
Hampshire courts Department of Health
and Human Services uh child support
vision and attorneys representing
clients who are seeking support um
support payments are not following with
emphasis uh the extent permitted by
federal law Clause as outlined in New
Hampshire um RSA title 43 chapter
458 16 Alpha and Roman numeral one uh
department and the Department of Health
and Human Services federal office of
Child Support Enforcement information
memorandum that we've been talking about
IM
9803 uh it's very important to emphasize
too that the 38 United States code a 38
USC
alpha1 uh non-il uh non assignability
and exempt status of benefits it
explicitly stat that payments of
benefits do or to become under any law
shall not be liable to attachment Levy
or seizure by Under by or under legal or
Equitable
process
whatsoever either before or after
receipt of the
beneficiary um this written testimony
was written in March uh prepared in
March of 2020 when the committee was to
hear that the family court had
unlawfully attach my disability
compensation without following the
proper enforement process I affirm that
VA compensation is not income it is not
renumeration of employment nor should it
could be uh should it be considered in
as such in any calculation in child
support their veterans or recipients of
both earned income and disability
benefits as in I as in my case and I
assert with my fellow brothers and
sisters and arms you serve still serve
or have served that disability benefits
are to be excluded from the calculation
of veterans disabled veterans based
support obligations based upon federal
law it is very important custodial
follow custodial parents follow the
Department of Health and Human Services
federal office of Child Support
Enforcement the information memorandum
90 IM 9803 for proper apportionment
process as it relates to veteran
benefits now this is the same process
followed when a veteran is unemployable
due to disability who is the the
recipient of
SSDI in this case a disabled veteran who
has veteran disabled V disability uh
benefits in Social Security disability
insurance should follow the again
DHHS federal office of Child Support
Enforcement information memorandum IM
9803 process and apply for any Child
Benefits under the Social Security
disability insurance
through the Social Security
Administration I thank you for your time
and
considerations and again I appreciate
your time with us today and hopefully um
we can get our message out there that
this needs to be taken care
of thank you all thank you Mr Jet Are
there any questions for Mr
jet uh I'm not seeing any here that
thank you thank you Mr jet thank you
very much for your time I appreciate it
you all have a good day
same
too uh next I'll call up uh Mark
plant Christina is he available take a
us I do not see him in the list
today okay uh next I'll call up
Christopher
Cy okay do you see him here I
don't
yeah you don't see him either no I do
okay for the committee I'm just uh I
have a list of public wanting to speak
and that's who I'm going through we do
have Mr
Frasier uh
with child support uh who's on who's on
and wants to testify um so I'm just
going through the list of uh people that
registered members of the P that
registered to testify
in right I think do have Mr ceny are you
there
sir yes I
am okay Mr
Cy hi everyone uh my name is Christopher
States Marine Corps uh four years active
duty I've been deployed overseas to
Afghanistan fought in combat uh I've
lost uh fellow service members in combat
uh and I am an 80% disabled veteran uh
from my
service um right now um I am a father of
four children um and I share my children
50% of the time with my ex-spouse
um and at this time uh my only income is
my veterans disability um I am in
constant pain every day and just you
know struggle to maintain any employment
as I have over the years and
um right now my main focus is taking
care of my children and providing the
best life to them as I can and um I am
being ordered to pay
um approximately 60% of my only income
which is my veterans disability in child
support payments for uh my ex who's also
working full-time and also able to uh
attend school over at uh Great Bay
Community College uh my spouse also uh
lives at home with her family uh rentree
and I have been ordered to pay again my
my only income uh at about 60% of it uh
to her and um it's leaving me uh
basically uh unable to care for myself
or my my children uh for the 15 out of
30 days while they're in my care uh
without the assistance of my family uh
my family is able to uh you know assist
me with everything I need at this time
but I need this process to be followed
the apportionment process because uh
they are calling my disability uh as a
pension that's how they're listing it in
the Child Support guideline
worksheet and um it is uh basically
leaving me uh you know unable to care
for my family without the assistance of
my family and um this is just you know
wrong I know it's happening to me and I
know it's happening to many other
veterans out there um and this just
needs to get fixed and the pment process
and um that's pretty much all all I have
to say is because it's directly
affecting me and my children and it's
not that I'm and I've never missed a
child support payment I've done
everything I'm supposed to do I've
followed all of the uh you know
directions that have been put on me and
this enforcment process is just not
being followed and they are taking uh
pretty much all of my income and giving
it to my spouse uh this also um
basically my spouse she's also receiving
all the state benefits and this is
really really hard for me too because
with four children um you know their
ages are six years old five years old
and then I have twins that are three um
I need to have them in daycare if I'm
going to attempt to work but um at this
time again my my disabilities are
preventing that and the expenses for all
the children are preventing that but uh
my spouse who's not following the
apportionment process she's receiving
all the state aid she's getting daycare
for free she's getting the food stamps
she's getting all of those state
benefits I've gone in and applied and I
was told uh my children are being
claimed by my spouse my ex spouse she's
receiving 100% of all benefits paid for
all those children and I have uh I
cannot access them because the state
will not pay out those benefits uh basic
for my family for the 15 out 30 days
they with me so my my ex spouse is
receiving all this benefits she's
getting my uh 60% of my disability um
and she's working full-time so she her
household is is got so much more uh
availability for for money and and all
that to support the children and I am
just being uh you know left behind
and uh if if this process was followed
um you know it would not put such a
hardship on myself and my four
children um again you know I went
through a very very volatile divorce uh
separation process and I had to fight to
to just prove that I'm uh you know
caring for my children and all that and
I and I was awarded legal residency for
all four children after going through
DCF and all that just to now uh you know
now I have my children with me and now
it's almost impossible to even you know
raise them put food on the table with uh
you know me being forced to pay almost
all the dollars I receed on a monthly
basis over to my ex spouse so I just
wanted to you know be able to provide
you know this is my testimony this is
happening directly to me and for
children uh identical twins that are
three a five-year-old and a six-year-old
and you know again they they're with me
15 out of 30 days and it's just uh you
know not right what's going going on I'm
I'm unable to work uh at this time I've
tried for many years and I I actually
was working before um I even went
through a a divorce process um I very
very unique situation I I had gained
appointment through my spouse's um
brother uh he referred me I'd come
straight out of the Marine Corps and he
referred me there and you know in our
divorce process there was restraining
orders all that all all dismissed and
thrown out um that cost me my job and so
I at the time I was working uh and it
was difficult uh again that job was
ripped out from underneath my feet from
a restraining order because uh you can't
have uh you know family members where
there's a restraining order working
together in the same building right next
to each other so I lost my job was fired
and the family court just said you know
you're making that money and they didn't
care that I'm just 80% disabled and and
again I I was rated at 80% disabled when
I was 23 years old uh I again I served
in the Infantry in the Marine Corps went
to Afghanistan and you know some of my
friends didn't come home and and the
ones that did come home we went through
uh some very very rough times and you
know I I would say all my close friends
that I served with they are all disabled
veterans uh you know and we are all in
in pain every single day I wake up my
back's in in in an awful condition uh
but I do what I need to do to support my
children and uh you know care for myself
but the apportionment process uh
definitely needs to be followed and
there's nothing that I can do you know
at this point um other than ask them to
follow it and they just say no and
pension and um that's that's pretty much
all I have if anyone has any questions
for me uh available to answer anything
very good uh I don't see any hands up
are there is there any member willing to
ask a
question uh CN n i i I do have a
question Mr sansy so if if this bill
were to go into to effect uh would pass
in your current status how much support
from you would would your children be
getting um so they would essentially
right now like I said my my uh spouse is
receiving all the state benefits uh
she's receiving uh you know daycare
housing stiens all that um which I'm
excluded from uh she has the kids half
the time she's working full-time and I
don't have a I don't have income I can't
afford the child care costs I'm I'm
unable to access those benefits and if
they did they would just even the
playing field the VA would look at you
know they they would review uh how they
do and they would see that I have the
kids 15 out of 30 days 15 nights they
are sleeping here with me under this
under my roof and
um uh basically it would just make it so
that this living situation the children
when they're with me that you know they
they have an equal uh living environment
they have the same amount of funding
coming in here just because right now it
it is completely an uneven weighted
scale it's just it's not fair and when I
am trying to have this Pro followed and
and when I say no this is my disability
uh you know they're looking at it and
going no that is a pension that is
income coming into you uh and it it is
just disability compensation and and
like I said uh uh 80% disabled you know
it's not a joke it's very serious and um
you know it affects myself and and all
the other disabled veterans out there uh
you know some people cannot work
um and and right now um I'm just seeing
this happen I've become aware of the
legal process that needs to be followed
and you know I just want to get my story
out there and and have everyone see that
you know this is happening people out
there it's causing some veterans that
have post-traumatic stress from uh being
in combat they come home and all of a
sudden now they're they're being ordered
to pay all their income and you know
it's the veteran Community you know
there's even more suicides from that I
know people that basically just give up
on their kids they they they are
exhausted so Mr sansy I
I I I think you answered my question
I what you're saying is that if this
bill were to go through in your opinion
the uh funding would be equal to your
ex's and your uh funding is that what
I'm hearing yes sir okay very good thank
you and H representative horn you have
on uh thank you for your testimony sir I
was wondering could you share me the ex
could you share with us the explanation
that you were given during the process
where the state decided that only your X
would be getting support if there's 50%
custody I would think that means the
support would be 50% as well yeah so I
can I can explain that for you sir um
again you got to bear with me for a
second because it's kind of a I can
speed up the story so um when I was
going through this whole divorce process
um I had no idea it was coming I love my
spouse everything was solid uh and but
we did you know argue from time to time
and she would always say you know when
we got an argument I want a divorce so
we uh one day uh normal everything I I
tell her I love her kiss her but goodbye
the kids goodbye come home from work and
they there are police greeting me at my
driveway with a restraining order um and
I had no idea what happened I had no
idea what was going on and at that
moment uh I went back to work the next
day told them hey I have a restraining
order on me uh and they immediately
fired me because my my brother-in-law
worked with me and they said you cannot
be here with restraining order on you
because it's against your your spouse
and their immediate family members I was
immediately fired for my job I lost my
house I lost everything because I
couldn't pay anymore I was only living
off of my veterans disability I had
multiple I had DCF investigations
against me for uh child abuse I had uh
police investigations for the same thing
you name it my my spouse claimed
everything possible against me I didn't
have my kids I didn't have anything I
agreed to do supervised visitation I
agree to do anything to get there and be
with my children and take care of them
because they are my my life they're
everything uh that I you know love and
care for so I immediately lost
everything I followed all the steps once
Family Court uh they they she was
claiming she wasn't getting any
compensation from me but I I kept her on
my bank account I kept giving her more
than uh she was spending approximately
$1,300 a month or more uh just accessing
the account and then the court went well
we want to start uh and this is while I
was still being uh evaluated for child
abuse if that was actually happening or
not uh they ordered me to pay child
support uh my my spouse's attorney said
that I was working full-time still even
though I've been fired uh they said that
I was receiving more money than I was in
disability and then they claimed that I
was making more in other veterans
benefits while I went to school all of
this was untrue and I didn't have my
children I I still haven't finalized my
divorce yet because there's been a
second investigation all of these
investigations of child abuse that have
been used and weaponized against me to
hurt me all claimed uh they were all
thrown out uh there was no abuse and the
the court they said the children should
be living with uh their father and they
changed their legal residence to my
house so I went from being an accused
abuser to Legal residence with me half
the time with her mom half the time with
me and it's been a nightmare uh like uh
the other uh person uh Mora Ryan who
gave testimony about um co-parenting it
is very difficult but at that time when
they issued this order I didn't have my
children they hadn't corrected it and
still to this day now I'm only receiving
my veterans disability as income nothing
else and they are saying that is a
pension we and uh you need to pay and
again my my spouse is receiving those
state benefits she's working full-time
she's getting me to pay her and it
leaves me financially strained exhausted
I have to take care of myself I got
injured in combat overseas my my my body
is in constant pain from this and um it
leaves me you know at a disadvantage
where I you know struggle to take care
of myself and you know how am I going to
continue to provide for these children
where they're taking 60% of my income
and this this process uh for of a
portion Min is supposed to be followed
for situations like this and
um that so so I think I answered your
question as to why was was issued
because it was as these investigations
were going on but now even as a proven
that I'm a good father I never did
anything the things she said I'm still
being forced to pay and I have the kids
with me 15 out of 30 days it doesn't
make any sense to me
but this would correct that this would
be able to allow me to go back into
family court and go hey guys this is the
apportionment process this is what needs
to be followed and and the VA would
determine uh you know the they would
actually send the payment directly to my
spouse if any of the money was
determined to go to her so they would
they would handle that all and it's just
being
avoided very good representative H did
you have a followup or you're good um I
don't see I don't see any other hand
sir uh next on the list I have Josh
Warren is he uh here Christina I will
here do not see him though if he is here
please raise your hand by pressing star
nine I don't see anyone okay uh next I
look I do not see David
no one by the name of Stephen again if
hand okay no one by the name of Stephen
[Music]
I do not see Timothy
chapne do not see Bron
champagne looks like representative rice
rice she's probably not able to unmute
herself oh there we go thank you um so
are we if someone called in what do they
press to
testify star nine will raise their hand
star nine will yeah she's asking them if
they're here to press star n to show
their hands and she could we could
you
okay who is
next I have uh Derek
champagne I you see Derek champagne okay
great here we go Mr
champagne here we go yes Mr
chairman very good
good afternoon I am retired specialist
Derek champagne of the United States
Army I serve proudly in honorably from
2009 to
2015 when I was medically retired in
2013 I was on a tour in Afghanistan and
was seriously injured in combat I
returned Stateside and spent two years
recovering in a wounded warrior program
in Fort Drum New
York I will never be able to do certain
things again after my accident and I
received 100% disability and had been
placed on the permanent total disability
list after returning home from
recovering a new battle presented
itself outside of being a soldier I'm a
loving father to two beautiful girls one
of which I have 5050 custody
of unfortunately the state of New
Hampshire has been including my
disability compensation in my child
support calculations leaving me
struggling to pull myself out of a
NeverEnding mountain of debt this
violates Federal IM
98-03 and I have been stripped of my
right to doe process to argue this clear
violation my inability to work and job
limitations required me to collect
Social Security to help pay my bills I
now receive 400 $411
a month after
$1,275 a month in child support is taken
from me my mortgage and truck payments
are tripled this amount until this
crippling and illegal action is stopped
myself as well as many other veterans
will be forced to continue to choose
between paying our bills and taking care
children so I ask people of the
committee to please pass
years and as far as veteran suicide uh
just last week I had a father of five in
my town that I live in commit suicide
because he was denied access to his
children and he couldn't afford an an
attorney
kids and this is a cold fact that a lot
of veterans
face is yes these programs are provided
for lowincome
veterans but when you
have almost $1,300 a month in your only
income that you have taken out for child
support
in living how are you going to be able
to afford an attorney to represent
yourself to make sure you're getting the
time that you need with your children
you um and that's all I have to say if
anyone has any questions I am available
does anybody have any questions I don't
see any hands up here thank thank you Mr
testimony uh next next on the list I
have uh Tim
penac just a moment I did see him
earlier all right here he is just one
Mr penac are you there I am um thank you
chairman long and thank you the
committee for uh listening to my
testimony um I also am a disabled
veteran um and uh my disability is
counted as a portion of of child support
um and I'm in the same situation as the
other veterans um I want to point out a
couple of things that came up in the
testimony during the day um so far um
first of all im9
98-03 is the information memorandum that
falls underneath us code 38 USC
5307 so in the earlier testimony by Mora
Ryan she said it's an information
memorandum it is simply the process
outlined by the Veterans Administration
under the veterans under the law USC
5307 I am 9803 is just the process so
there is a federal law calling for aor
apportionment for the for the funds and
as my other fellow veterans have stated
the state is not following that
process um in representative horn made
an earlier comment regarding regarding
the apportionment process a lot of this
alludes to HB 362 I was present when U
the Casey Center presented um the latest
report and there's a discussion I know
that this is this is um in in research
or uh in study regarding
362 what we are asking as veterans is
simply for the state to follow the
federal guidelines and laws as it
relates to our disability compensation
that's all we're asking as a state to do
do that we're not asking to take money
away we're not this money is not a
portion of this money is allocated and
you can pull go to the VA website and
they actually have the schedule and you
can look to see how much compensation
you get on what percentage you can see
how much money that if you have one
child or two or three or four I have
four children I have my children half
the time all that is public knowledge
and part of that money is allocated
toward them and the portion process
allocates that money to those for the
children now the question about how much
of that gets allocated in split between
both parents if you have 50/50
custody that's an issue that's in front
of this committee ref regarding HB
362 but the federal government is
looking at this the VA process is
looking at this and
saying we will take care of the
apportionment for the VA money I hate to
say it but they're doing a part of the
responsibility that we're not doing in
this
state and that's what 362 is about so
all we're asking as veterans who have
served our country and have been injured
is you just follow the law and follow
the follow VA law that VA regulations
that's all happy to take questions from
there thank you Mr uh Pak uh are there
any
questions I I don't see any
penac next I'll
look it looks like representative hor
does have a question representative H
question uh I would like to offer two
pieces of advice which may speed up this
process the first piece of advice is if
uh Miss Dyer is running from the same
list that is in front of you perhaps she
can have the person speaking in the
lobby and then bring the next person on
the list who is speaking into the lobby
and keep them muted so that we don't
have to continually wait for somebody to
search through a list and the second
piece is I would really appreciate if
our microphones were under our control
because I think we're all able to decide
whether or not we can mute or unmute
ourselves um if a dog starts barking
Shir go ahead and mute somebody but it's
just very limiting and I'm not very
good is Mr uh
brussell available uh Christina I do not
see him do not see
him uh
Bourne
brookshaw and he'll have to come in here
comes good afternoon Mr brookshaw how
you doing very good uh uh my name is Bon
brookshaw um I am a Afghanistan in Iraq
War but um in 2007 um I was hit by a
roadside bomb and shot twice and I will
tell you right now lying dead on that
ground is a cakewalk compared to what
I'm going through right now with
this um the child support custody
guidelines my daughter is seven years
old um for the past five years I have
been treated like garbage I have
looked down upon and I've been refused
to see my daughter I
make toally and permanently disabled um
I make uh $3,200 a month with that's
included my dependent for my
daughter I pay almost $800 a month in
child support which includes medical
which includes any activity and food and
clothing here I can get champ VA for my
daughter but my ex
refuses and she gets her own work
insurance I could I've gone to the court
numerous times in regards to this issue
and the judge looks at me laughs at me
and says well figure something
out um I have been homeless and then I
finally got on my feet and got a
one-bedroom apartment where my daughter
was able to come in and actually have a
bed to sleep in well my ex went to child
services and stated that she didn't feel
comfortable with just one bedroom so I
get went from a $800 bedroom uh
apartment to a $1,200 apartment and now
if you think about it 800 minus 32 is um
20 what
$2,400 all right minus $1,200 you're
looking another $1,200 left plus car
fees electric fees um food for my
daughter clothing that I have to pay
even though it's included in child
support she I have
gone through the ringer with the courts
I've had lawyers take my money and run
to try and help me gain this support
from them I am from Rhode Island
originally I moved up here when my was
pregnant with my daughter so we be her
family I am the only person up here I
don't have friends up here my family is
not up here the only people that I talk
to are the veterans in this group here I
don't have support up here like she
lives at home with her parents she pays
rentree she has a car she doesn't pay
for food she makes $5,000 a month and
yet we have 5050 custody this has killed
me it
has hurt me mentally I suffer from PTSD
I suffer from traumatic brain injury
I've had over 10
surgeries um I can't
work I can't stand up for more than an
hour without being in
pain and I've been it's been used
VA Li to what I can do and suppli for my
daughter my daughter for Christmas I
went through toys for Tops and I one
thing that I heard through one of the
testimonies this morning is
that that one of the children get paid
food uh at lunchtime at school well my I
do that for my daughter at
times
and that is actually something that
helps us all um and to not recognize
that um is is kind of frustrating
because veterans like us need that stuff
and it's not a bad thing for kids to get
it it's actually a good thing um I have
5050 custody yeah
I maybe see my da% of the time because
of the fact that maybe I'm behind on
child support I'm behind on child
support because I'm paying $800 a month
and my bills are I can't even cover my
own bills I I put all my money towards
my daughter I didn't get a stimulus
check this year because I'm behind on
child support and if you look at it
people that didn't get stimulus checks
this year were people who were behind on
child support felons got them and people
who were behind on child some good
fathers who are there for the kids can't
afford to pay in or late no matter what
they do can't even get helped by the
government um
I try and I am the best father that I
could be I am laughed at by the courts
all the time my judge was actually just
retired and she was forcibly retired
because she was under
investigation numerous times for false
allegations in and being biased against
men and when we brought this incident up
about the child supports and the VA
benefits she laughed at all of even my
judge and said well you're gonna have to
figure out a way to pay it because I
don't care now that to me is something
that is not right we keep fighting I'm
not gonna keep fighting and it something
needs to be done and I pray every day
that I hope that this
passes because not only will stop
suicidal fathers but it will bring kids
closer to their fathers and fathers are
just as important as mothers money
involved no money involved it matter
fathers play the biggest one of the
biggest roles in that kid's life
daughters look up to fathers sons look
up to fathers um and it it's frustrating
to go around and see that people who
fought for their country are
continually being looked down upon the
courts and it's all about money for
their kids it's all about money you got
to pay this you got to pay and when you
can't you go to jail you can't pay your
child support you go to jail and as a
veteran that's not okay when a mother
refuses to see her or refuses to follow
the parenting plan of court or she gets
a slap on the wrist or the Jud comes up
with an excuse oh maybe because she was
this way but when we miss a day in child
support or mon in child support behind
you go to jail and somebody said it
after I believe it was at $5,000 you can
file federal charges on them to me that
is not okay when the government gives
you only certain amount of money $200
Max for a child and you have to pay
almost three times two times much as
that that's not okay and it puts the
father and when the father can't pay it
and then he can't pay his rent and then
the other half ends up taking the child
away because she doesn't feel
comfortable because you can't find a
place to live in that's not okay
um I am very frustrated I am sorry that
it's had to come to this I
wish we could all work together to
resolve this um I am a very devoted
father devoted veteran Purple Heart
veteran and it's something that I
cherish and I want my daughter to grow
up knowing that her father did
everything in his power to make sure she
had everything that she needed to
survive in this world um and that's all
I have to say thank you uh Mr brookshaw
no no need to uh no need to apologize
either I could understand your
frustration um uh there are a couple
questions representative rice you got a
question thank you it's it's not really
a question I'm very sorry but
representative pan City had to leave the
meeting because he had Wi-Fi issues and
now he needs Christina to let him back
in okay thank you sorry no that's okay
thinking I'm sorry I'm looking for
her oh uh all right thank you thank you
thank you
chair um thank you Mr brookshaw for your
testimony I did not want to miss the
opportunity um to thank you and everyone
that has come before us today as
Veterans for your service and um I just
want to share that
it it is um unacceptable that people
such as yourself who's trying to be a
good dad um has to go through this and
I'm sorry that that's happening thank
you that's all I wanted to say thank you
very much are there any further
questions I don't see any here uh again
thank you uh Mr
look I do not see Greg
okay uh then the last name that I have
is Brenda
town let see Miss town here she's there
great uh good afternoon everybody um and
thank you for uh hearing us today my
name is Brenda town and I represent um a
group of parents so I unwittingly got
involved in helping parents about a year
and a half ago and I uh I guess I lead a
group of about
3500 um folks that are participate on
Facebook with um me and um this past
year um we decided to get we decided to
become unver virtual in meet for the
first time and we had about 40 parents
um uh fathers a few mothers but mostly
fathers show up and of the 40 that
showed up um I was shocked to find out
that 20 of them were
homeless and the majority of them were
veterans and I I had no idea um what was
happening and so as I fed phone calls
daily and um emails and and messages I
became really familiar with what was
happening to this group of parents and
what I came to find out is that these uh
were disabled veterans and instead of
having their disability pay that was
supposed to be um separate um and it was
separate based on the 38 USC
5301a one um and not um included in
child support calculations without
exception all of them had had that
happen to them while they were in family
court and so the child support orders
that were being issued were on um their
disability and if they worked it would
be a combination of their disability and
their income and it was creating a
tremendous hardship and making it
impossible for them to maintain an
apartment and pay the support as well as
keep up with their medications and other
things that um that were bills in their
life and what I really came to
understand is it was preventing them
from being the dads that they really
wanted to be um when you're living in
your car and you're financially strapped
you just can't be involved in your kids'
life um the way that you want to be and
so as the more I I came to understand
that we as a state were not following
these federal guidelines um the more
passionate I got about this and I really
wanted to get behind this bill and I
hope you all do too because um there is
a very clear defined Federal process
that we as a state have have not been
following and this process was designed
to protect this group of people because
of situations that go Way Beyond the
scope of what we would typically
consider in family courts and there is a
reason why our federal government
created this separation of veterans
disability pay from other forms of
compensation and they kept it unique so
that these men and women who served
would be protected and unfortunately we
have failed them and we have failed them
miserably and as you heard from the
testimonies today this is huge issue
that we are responsible for
fixing so there is a an apportionment
process that is laid out and U people
have talked about it today the IM
9803 that the V veterans administration
will administer and based on an
assessment of the households determine
if some of that disability need needs to
be balanced in other households and we
need to let the VA do that and by doing
that we help protect our veterans and we
also balance the household so both
parents can participate uh to the level
that they need to participate the other
thing that I I really am concerned about
as a New Hampshire resident is that
because we have been not following these
federal laws we have
inadvertently created an an
inappropriate matching of title 4D funds
that are being matched against these
inflated child support orders and that
could put us in really hot water and I
wanted to flag that as well for the
family committee because not only is
this the federal law and the right thing
to do but by us not following it um
correctly it exposes us as well and so I
think our hearts based on everything
I've heard from uh people around the
room we all want to support our vets so
I just humbly ask you guys to um
Institute the same um federal guidelines
that are out there to be executed and
embedded in the uh language of our um
guidelines here in New Hampshire and
again thank you very much and um I
appreciate everything that you guys do I
know you hear a lot of stuff uh coming
at you all the time and it's a it's a
lot of work but I I appreciate that
you're you're listening today and that
you stand in the Gap to fix some these
holes for people that are hurting and
I'd be glad to take any questions thank
you Miss town uh I have a question from
representative
French yes thank you chair Mr chair and
thank you for taking my phone my
question sorry Brenda um I've heard the
term and it that there's an
apportionment process
um repeatedly this afternoon um Moira
Ryan was talking about she's been
waiting 10 years and several of the men
have mentioned this
years in my um narrow experience it does
not take years and um I believe some of
the veterans who testified uh today
might have seen other veterans go
through the process I believe in some of
the
documentation that is provided to the
committee that they actually have
examples of apportionments that went
through the process and were closed in a
timely manner so that you know it's a
horrible thing that's that that has
happened uh to um that the uh first
person who testified today um and that
shouldn't happen but it is not at least
my experience or exposure um it should
take about 15 days once the VA receives
the paperwork that is what the
commitment is on the bottom of the form
that I
have thank
you very good I don't see any
other hands up uh so thank you Miss
Town um thank you Miss Dyer is there any
other member of the public who
um would want that hasn't testified I I
have a phone call up here with somebody
a phone number with somebody's hands up
so the only uh there's nobody else on
the list uh that I see that registered
other than um Mr Tim Frasier from Child
Support okay uh and then uh if you
wanted to um very good well well we'll
see I I I see Mr cooning has his hands
up so I don't know if he needs to
register
or do I call upon some people uh well
why don't I call up Mr Frasier from uh
New Hampshire Department of Health and
Human Services child support and then
that's the last person I have listed and
will'll ask if any member of the public
uh who hasn't spoke uh speak
can you hear me he's muted there he goes
okay uh thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Tim Frasier um I
council with uh the Bureau of Child
Support Services as part of
DHHS um and uh I first want to thank uh
representative baldasaro uh for his
service and his advocacy for veterans
and uh the the veterans who have
testified here today but unfortunately I
do have to speak in opposition to this
bill I it is really based on a basic
misconception about federal law um and
I'll try to tackle that first uh which
is concerning the apportionment
process the apportionment process that's
contained in federal law concerning VA
benefits does not modify
child support it is actually an
enforcement
Tool uh if I can explain uh step back
just a little
bit Federal Law requires all forms of
income to be included in the child
support guidelines that's a requirement
of every state plan for child support in
order for State 4D or child support
agencies to receive federal funding
um and uh New Hampshire does in fact uh
Define income gross income very broadly
to conform to the federal
requirements uh it includes all forms of
income earned unearned uh wages uh
commissions uh everything uh tips and
all forms of uh of government uh
benefits as well too including Social
Security unemployment compensation and
including veterans benefits including
veterans disability benefits the reason
for this is simple it's a matter of
public policy when child support orders
are determined the court has to be able
to look at the entire picture uh it's
got to be able to see exactly what it is
and how uh all forms of income each
party has how they live uh you know what
sources they have and uh to be able to
include that in the calculation of child
support now the New Hampshire Supreme
Court in Mr Bronstein's case recently
confirmed that the inclusion of VA
benefits and the calculation of Child
Support is consistent with federal law
uh it belongs there it must be
considered in the determination of an
appropriate child support
order now VA disability benefits are a
specially protected category of
income where almost everything else
wages even uh disability benefits
through a social security are uh
assignable U not assignable but they're
attachable garnishable by uh wage
assignment uh by child support uh for
the payment of Child Support so if
you're having ordinary income or even if
you're on Social Security Disability a
notice will go to that source of income
and your child support will be paid
through that
garnishment federal law protects
veterans disability benefits in a
special way that is not
allowed uh that is to protect the the
veterans from creditors and others um in
a special way Rec federal law
recognizing that this is special
circumstances these are disabled
veterans uh that doesn't change in any
way the underlying child support order
that has to be determined on a caseby
casee basis it only uh affects the way
the child support order is
enforced now VA benefits do include
allocations generally include
allocations for veterans children uh so
those amounts are included
in uh the the total award and those are
paid directly to the disabled
veteran now once those disability
benefits have been paid to the veteran
the brunstein case and other cases have
have confirmed that courts can require
that child support be paid out of those
funds
uh but they can't be uh directly
garnished from the
VA except through the apportionment
process in cases where child support is
not being paid where the veteran is not
adequately supporting their
children uh the VA said that's an
exception part of our uh of our mission
here is to not only support the veteran
but also to support the veterans
families there's the a door opens
through the apportionment process where
not the pay or but the paye can seek uh
an apportionment of the VA disability
benefits to gain access to what would
otherwise not be directly
garnishable that is the ement process it
is not a redetermination of how much
child support should be paid
in any way that is the Court's job the
va's job is to protect the veteran and
to support the veteran and the family so
that is the basic
misunderstanding that is a little bit
confusing uh when you first look at this
but I I do understand where the veterans
are coming from they see that there is
an extra allocation for families in the
veterans disability benefits and they're
apparently thinking that by this
apportionment process that will limit
their child support liability to that
amount but that is not the
case uh the uh informational memorandum
IM 9803 that keeps being referred to
that is actually a federal office of
Child Support informational memorandum
to 4D agencies such as the Bureau of
Child Support Services here in New
Hampshire describing how to access
disability benefits being paid to
veterans that wouldn't otherwise be
accessible through this supportment
process that is to help the payes who
have a claim like uh Miss Ryan I believe
it was who testified earlier who is
seeking to directly gain access to uh
the veterans disability benefits through
this
process so um unfortunately this bill is
based on a basic misunderstanding
of apportionment and the federal law
behind
it uh and the consequence of this would
be to put the state out of federal
compliance in regard to what has to be
included in consideration of income for
child support calculation
purposes and it really goes against the
public
policy of not only child support and the
support of veterans families but also
goes against the veterans Administration
policy of supporting both the veteran
and their families because if you take
the amount of uh of the disability
benefit out of the calculation as we
have heard many of these Disabled Vets
have little or no other
income that would result in a
$50 a month minimum order of child
support and that would be the only
obligation the vet would have to their
families how many children uh the
inevitable result of that would be that
the families would have less support uh
less ability to uh self on self-reliance
economically uh they would be forced in
many instances to seek public assistance
and uh which the taxpayers have to pick
up um that that's the unfortunate
consequence of this um so uh I I respect
the uh the efforts here I understand
this is very well intentioned it is just
not what the sponsors and the supporters
believe it is uh and I'd be happy to
questions there we go thank you uh thank
you Mr Fraser are there any uh questions
from the and I do have questions
uh representative uh pen city thank you
Mr chairman um I'd like to ask
um speaker if um under title four did
the courts receive any extra funds based
on the child support payments they
receive not on the child support
payments thank you for your question uh
representative thank you the uh the 4D
funding is for the support of the 4D
program which is in New Hampshire the
Bureau of Child Support Services um
every state every territory and uh most
Indian tribes actually have 4D programs
uh because it's very much tied into uh
the uh uh TANF program and so forth
through reimbursement to the state and
federal programs the uh the federal
government supports child support as
sort of the Keystone of that at a 66%
rate so uh our the Bureau of Child
Support Services in New Hampshire does
receive 66% of its funding from the
federal sources now also one of the
requirements of every state plan of
Child Support is that child support
cases get special treatment in court
they get what is called called expedited
process in other words it has to go
faster than ordinary cases uh because
there are so many of them basically and
they have to be done
quickly uh so in that expedited process
uh cases can't be heard by judges uh
they have to be heard by judicial
referees or marital Masters and that uh
cost for the judges marital Masters and
other court costs is 66% reimbursable
through the 4D program in order to make
it faster and support that Court program
it has nothing to do with the amount of
Child Support ordered and as a matter of
fact what it has the the orders have to
be compliant with all 4D regulations in
other words they can't be excessive or
outside the guidelines uh they have to
be compliant with the guidelines in
order to um be consistent with the
program and and and receive the 66%
funding so yes and no courts do get
reimbursed for 4D cases but not for any
particular
orders uh representative Corson you have
a
question uh thank you uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question Mr Fraser uh could you just
explain again briefly how it is the
present situation protects someone like
Miss berer in her testimony you
mentioned that quite clearly but I
missed some of those details and I'd be
helped by that thank you Miss Ryan is
saying
that uh as a disabled vet herself and uh
and is seeking um to enforce child
support against another disabled vet
correct as the other parent uh she is
accessing the apportionment
process which is a request to the VA
Administration to actually have some or
all of the child support that is that
the other parent is obligated to pay
taken out of their VA benefits
directly that is not otherwise available
because of the way federal law works you
can't directly garnish those VA benefits
except through the apportionment process
now that apportionment process does not
alter the underlying child support order
it doesn't limit the obligation of the
veteran it just is a determination by
the veterans administration of how much
can if any should be taken out of the
veterans disability benefits for the
payment of support based on the
application of the paye the one who was
support and uh and representative horn
question so there's no doubt that this
process is not serving everybody equally
we've heard plenty of testimony today
that contributes to that that
statement what I'm curious about more
than anything else is how DHHS
justifies leveraging a disability check
for somebody
who's getting that check because they
can't work to the point where they're
not able to provide a safe and stable
environment for their for the kids
receiving the child support wouldn't it
make more sense to keep
that child support disab wouldn't that
be make more sense to keep disability
separate from Child Support dues so that
the disability would be used to provide
for the
children thank you representative horen
uh that is really two separate
issues uh DHHS the the Bureau of Child
Support Services does not determine how
much Someone's Child Support obligation
should be that is the Court's job uh the
Bureau of Child Support Services gets
the orders and is obligated under the
law to enforce to the best of our
ability now through that process uh
disability ordinary Social Security
Disability is garnishable by income
assignment it payment can come directly
through through the income assignment
but we can't determine whether that
amount is fair or not to the person who
is paying that's the courtz
job uh and uh
so uh we don't we enforce orders we
don't create them the modification
process is there for anybody who is not
able to meet the payments they can apply
to the court to try to get their order
changed
again that's a process that's out of our
control but we do assist people in it if
someone has a change of circumstance or
three years have gone by they can simply
ask us to help them get the case back
that uh representative
rice oh I'm sorry representative horn
has a followup go ahead representative
horn thank you Mr chairman um I thought
I heard you state when you began your
testimony that you're in opposition to
this bill so wouldn't that suggest
you're taking a position that you have
just now tried to say is the Court's
position to
take thank you Representative no I I I
think I'm being consistent here uh we
have to oppose this bill because the
change it would make to the child
support guidelines would put us out of
compliance with the requirements of our
state plan the state plan requires that
all forms of income earned unearned
disability and so on and so forth be
included in consideration by the courts
in the child support
guidelines uh we don't we don't issue
orders it's the court that issues the
guidelines representative rice thank you
Mr chairman my question is actually for
you do we have anyone here from the
courts that could possibly answer some
of these questions as to why we have
veterans on the line who have put their
lives on the line for our country and
are homeless because of these guidelines
where is the court I want to hear from
them I'm sorry I'm upset this has been
very trying to listen
to Y well no need to apologize
representative rice um I don't see any
any member of the court system um
in the attendees uh
side uh so unfortunately we we don't
have them representing uh
representing
um wanted to be heard on this
m looks like he needs
him there you go representative um
representative rice um yeah I feel I
feel much the same way but uh and this
is is a question to
uh uh to uh Mr Frasier um when you when
you talk about the court and you talk
about the
plan isn't it the legislature that
actually determined
that plan and what the court can and
cannot
do thank you representative Baran
absolutely and the and the legislature
has um implemented the child support
guidelines um in compliance with the
federal
requirements um that's what the
legislature has chosen to do and part of
that of course is to keep the state
consistent with the requirements uh the
federal requirements of the state plan
for child support um that is a
prerequisite for the funding for both uh
the child support the buau of Child
Support Services and to a certain extent
to the tanif program it's also reliant
on compliance with the state plan for
child
support um so the legislature past
legislatures have made the decision that
this is important and to have a
functioning Bureau of Child Support
Services that is funded by the the
federal government and uh um like I said
that's the same nationally every state
every territory and many uh tribal
agency tribes have 4D agencies uh and
they all have to comply with the federal
guidelines if this bill were to pass um
I would be back or someone else would be
back from Child Support next year
requesting that this be changed so that
we could be funded
again follow up rosan
Baran uh yes um so um uh there is a
requirement every four years that the
legislature review the child support
guidelines um and make appropriate
modifications and isn't that the purpose
of what we had is HB
362 which is now
in um interim study so isn't that a
place that we can address some of these
issues particularly those related to
disabled
veterans absolutely that is the idea for
the periodic review uh every four years
there is to be a uh review of the child
support guidelines issues such as this
and the issue that keeps coming up uh
throughout this discussion of shared
parenting and how to provide for it
within the
guidelines uh that's all part of the
guidelines review and the subsequent uh
recommendations and and legislative
action that really is we believe the
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question again sir so I need
some help with some of these definitions
what is the state plan and what is its
origin thank you uh represent for the
state plan is from the Social Security
Act uh title
4D uh it includes uh the re specific
requirements that every state or
territory or whatever entity has to uh
put into place it's a set of laws uh
concerning uh child support including
the guidelines every uh every 4D agency
and uh excuse me back up one more every
state has to have in place uh the state
plan for child support in order to
receive 4D
funding um so uh as a 4D agent
uh as I was saying we get our a big
amount of our funding through this
Federal funding because the state is in
compliance with uh the state plan for
child support there's other uh state
agencies that also have state plans that
have uh Federal requirements this is
really no different except that the
funding level is significantly higher
ones follow up thank you Mr chairman so
the origin of the plan that is specific
to New Hampshire is the federal
government or is the state
legislature uh the state plan itself is
dictated by the Social Security Act
federal law and uh through related
regulations it is up to the state
legislature then to uh to have laws on
the books on a state level uh to comply
with those Federal
requirements um
so uh that that's the relationship
between the
two representative horn followup uh last
one Mr chairman I
promise
so the FED gives us the skeleton under
which we have to be compliant in order
to receive federal funding putting meat
and skin on that skeleton is the state's
responsibility so then
would that
mean that sorry would that make this
bill violate federal statute and which
uh federal law and which federal law
would they be violating if we adopted
this bill well I've included the
specific citation in my my written
testimony but it has to do with the uh
the Federal Regulations uh specific to
child support guidelines which require
that um all for forms of income be
included in consideration under the
guidelines and uh I if you I refer you
to the brunstein case issued by the
Supreme Court uh in February of this
year where the Supreme Court looked at
the child support guidelines and agreed
that uh the inclusion of veterans
disability benefits is consistent with
those federal guidelines and uh I
believe the the actual citation is
45 uh CFR 3
2.56
C1 but that that's included in my uh
written
deimon thank you Mr chair um Mr Frasier
thank you for coming today to testify
but I I do have a question in so far as
the Supreme Court
ruling Supreme Courts as every other
court rule um with the fact that they
interpret the law isn't that correct uh
true and uh the Supreme Court of New
Hampshire's the last word on on uh all
form on all determinations of what the
law is in New Hampshire uh except for
constitutional issues that could be
appealed to the Supreme Court thank
followup thank you so isn't it true that
um this same issue could be fought in a
court of law and another judge May
man therefore throwing this ruling out
isn't that
correct uh this would require the New
Hampshire Supreme Court to overturn
itself it would have to be right another
case right that's possible
sure so final followup Mr followup sure
thank you so isn't it possible that if
legislation that the New Hampshire
Supreme Court can in fact uphold this
legislation due to its interpretation of
both federal and state
law okay uh thank you for the question
representative Simone and uh I don't
think that there this if this law were
passed it wouldn't be in violation of
any state law what it would do is simply
put the state out of
compliance with the Federal regulations
concerning child support guidelines that
has implications for funding and as I
was saying here in my testimony the real
implication is that uh this could
potentially lessen the amount of support
for children children of disabled
veterans significantly and effectively
impoverish them and require more Public
Assistance uh that's the real effect
final okay you have to unmute yourself
deimon Christina can we unmute there we
go okay so if I may make one final
comment um in conjunction with uh
representative Baran statement
concerning House Bill
362 and Encompass some of what is going
on in this bill as well it's not going
to impoverish um children and it it's
only going to enhance the uh child
support uh guidelines and and and that's
just my opinion and I thank you okay uh
representative
French uh thank you Mr chair and um
representative deimon covered what I was
going to ask so I will not ask a
question okay very good um I don't see
any other questions from the
committee uh so thank you thank you Mr
Frasier thank
you and uh Miss Dyer that that is all I
have uh that
registered um do you know of any other
member of the public that is interested
in testifying on House Bill 17160
there are um seven uh folks that are
that have their hands up um two of which
three of which we have already testified
um there are a few folks um that are
listed there if you wanted to recognize
them but to my knowledge uh we don't
have a registered email from
them but that's your call of course okay
so I have a Don bulock is he available
he is here we
go Mr bulock
uh yes sir can you hear me yes great uh
well first of all let me thank the
committee uh for their time uh I wasn't
able to register because I just found
out about this today so I apologize uh
for not following the procedure thank
you Al balesar uh sir representative for
putting this legislation forward clearly
some difficult decisions to be made I'm
100% disabled veteran I'm not affected
in the same way the other veterans are
uh but I have been a veterans advocate
for the last 31 months since my
retirement from the US military I've
done this uh I'm a national Advocate a
state Advocate uh
and uh our veterans are in a very
serious situation here as you as you
have heard and the testimony about
putting Children at Risk is also
concerning but I have talked to Veterans
under bridges I've talked to them uh in
homeless areas across this state and I
am uh very very concerned that their um
disability pay would be uh considered uh
as um you know in in the process uh and
and I think that this is a a a bill that
must be passed it must be considered uh
and I am an advocate for it uh and I am
speaking to you as a veterans Advocate
and as a veteran and a retired military
member uh and not in any other capacity
so thank you for your time uh I hope
that you passed this bill uh and uh I am
grateful to have the opportunity to
speak thank you very
much thank you Mr bulu Mr uh
representative Corson did you have a
question to Mr bul duck yes I do okay
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
bulock the question is do you know
whether not New Hampshire is an outlier
across the country in terms of this
situation arising within different
states uh it is my uh understanding that
uh this situation uh is experienced by
veterans across the country uh I
wouldn't call it an uh an outlier
perhaps but I believe that there are
some things at the federal level that
must be changed uh in order for the
states to be able to do these things uh
much more practically and take care of
children and their veterans um but uh so
you will see this in other states yes
sir follow up M representative Carson so
quickly do you have any advice about how
to do that from our point of view how
can we
help well I think you know like I have
done uh contacting our Congressional
leadership in Washington DC um of course
that hasn't been very effective for me
uh and I'm I am pursuing another course
of action to uh to have an effect on
that as you're probably all aware but um
uh really advocating to them uh I've
written to other veterans I've written
to the uh uh Veteran Affairs and I've
called the white house uh as well uh and
and uh you know discuss this with the
white house as well uh to try and get
these you know the the federal I don't
call them loopholes but gaps president's
doing excellent to support our veterans
but it falls inside a bureaucracy that
has all these loopholes and gaps and
things that they hadn't considered or
things they didn't change uh and so we
find ourselves in that problem so
appealing to our federal Representatives
is how I'm trying to do it now thank you
very much you're welcome uh so seeing no
more hands up uh thank you Mr balduck
you you're welcome
sir could we ask Mr balduck if you have
a moment to email your information to
the HCS uh inbox just to
register uh yes I can do
that okay uh I had Senator Carson up
here but it doesn't look like she's here
Quinn okay I'll bring Mr Quinn on just a
moment
Mr
Quinn
hello go ahead Mr Quinn hi my name is
Sergeant Quinn um I was just curious a
30311 case closure for
um criteria the title 4D agency can
close a
case um when it has a medically verified
total impermanent
disability and the the state determines
that the non-custodial parent is no
income or assets available that can be
levied or attached for support it also
says further that non-o parent sole
income when proven to be SSI or SSDI
won't be attached and the case will be a
clo a Clos so I'm just
curious why he didn't mention that in
his
opposition
also
um SSI and SSDI from the social security
protection act of 2004 Social Security
section 20742 USC 407a says that Social
Security disability insurance and Social
Security Supplemental Income won't be uh
shall not be transferred or assignable
at law or equity and none of the money
paid or payable or rights existing under
this title shall be subject to execution
Levy attachment garnishment or other
legal
process
lastly excuse me I'm sorry I'm jumping
around um they amended last year 11 USC
10 a and they changed paragraph sub
paragraph
b um to reflect
that except any retired pay excluded
under the subclause shall include
retired pay under shall include retired
pay under chapter 61 or title 10 only to
the extent that such retired pay exceeds
the amount of retired pay to which the
debtor would otherwise be entitled if
retired under any provision of title 10
other than chapter
61 not all military retirement is the
same and HSS is trying to
to kind of convince you of that fact
that that the retirement is all the same
not every veteran serves 20 years and so
medical retirements that's where that
protection is for that's why the
apportionment should be done so that the
secretary can determine whether or not
the veteran served 20 years and is
waving a portion of his earned income
retirement or if he is a disabled
veteran who is unable to provide income
for his
dependent when that's the case they're
entitled to Social Security disability
insurance at which point Social Security
provides 55 to
56% of
the awarded Social Security
Insurance via a schematic trust directly
to the dependants so the dependants are
receiving 55% of
that money directly paid to them through
Social
Security because they're indent and
unable to provide for their family
that's all I had to say Thank you Mr
Quinn uh representative rice did you
she needs to be unmuted Christina yeah
except sometimes takes a
moment okay I don't have a question for
him I need to talk to you for a second
um representative long because I
received a message from Senator Carson
who's hearing who was supposed to
introduce um SV 295 at 2 o'clock she has
to be on another call in four minutes I
also have members of M
of the Republican caucus side who have
to leave for work shortly so I don't
know um what we're going to be able to
do whether we call this question and
vote on it or um if we can recess and
schedule another day because this has
gone on now um for almost three hours
and we've gone way past the two o'clock
hearing to which we have people waiting
for
uh yeah I appreciate those comments
representative rice I I am uh I wanted
to give everybody the opportunity to
speak I didn't know if this was gonna go
three hours or two hours or five
hours I I understand I have places to be
uh uh so I did see
uh actually this is the last person Mr
Quinn was the last person that I have on
unless I apologize representative long
um we did have someone who did register
um while we were speaking um again yeah
I know but I thought I thought that see
I knew that this was I knew this was
going to happen that people are going to
register while we're sitting here in a
three-hour public hearing and and so now
we have no idea how much longer this is
going to go on and I think it's I think
if anything you need to at least recess
this hearing we can come back to it but
you have to get to SP 295 which you
scheduled for
o' because now we're making all those
people sit and wait and and can't I I
understand that historically in a house
that has what happened plenty of times I
had a scheduled meeting at 10: and
waited till two o'clock in the afternoon
to introduce a bill I I get that I I
don't like that that happens but that
that's out of my control so we have one
more that there's there's other people
with their hands up but they've already
testified I'm not going to have them
testify again uh so we have one more and
then we could close this hearing uh and
that is I believe is that Robert Thomas
uh yes it is okay uh Mr
Thomas yes can you hear me I can yes can
you hear me
yes I just like to thank the panel for
taking this last uh call and I'm almost
sitting here in tears I've been
listening to this testimony for the last
three hours uh I'm a combat veteran down
here in Florida this is a global issue
and I'll be brief
uh my brothers and sisters who have bare
arms I'm a former Ranger combat veteran
of Panama in the Gulf War era and I've
battled the courts here in Florida for
the last five years I I just want to
Simply
say title 38
USC code 5301 and
5307 was put in place for veterans like
those that Miss rice heart goes out to
CU I I saw you ma'am I watched you
others who are taking this a and and and
and sincerely and understanding Mr
Fraser takes a take on what the state
allows to rip us off somewhere people
have forgot that federal funds everybody
sitting on this panel pay their taxes
and you paid for Tanis you paid for me
to be free today and I'm talking about
from expense of losing family friends at
War coming back home and as my brother
bushot stated this is the worst battle
I've had to get home 22 years later I
went back to VA at 2015 and have only
been receiving benefits after my
children are grown my fight has been
with aers through the child support
systems the court system does not care
to hear what Veterans of sin it is
absurd I am a Paul that the people I
went to die and fight for look at me
like I'm nobody when I've been a soldier
in the Army I fought for you I fought
for my free Liberties yours in this
world for as we speak today and how we
stand and seek to call ourselves
American iord any child not being able
honor to have food on the table clothing
on their back Etc but we don't know the
intricacies or the personal algy will
happen in these families when they
divorce I've gone through divorce I'm
remarried today but with that
said title 38 clears all that Mr Frasier
wants to allude to the fact that the
state federal government does not care
about children does not care about the
the parent when it comes to child
support the law is written very simply
is to recoup the funding of the federal
expenditures through tanip that they
have put out there that's what title for
DS4 it's not even a real court but what
they do is allude to the fact they pat
their pockets there's a kitty called
dispersement that the so-called judg is
getting paid from the hearing officer
gets paid from nobody wants to talk
about that story Mr Fraser want to make
it seem like they're doing us to some
type of favor but the federal government
has already been very clear Congress May
15 2017 this is you I'm app Paul people
don't are not aware of this if you guys
will look it up May 15 how versus how
killed the Rose versus Rose that these
courts Local District have been using
against veterans when we go before them
to throw us offic say no we can use
these monies no you can't use this money
it says very clearly before after
payments due to become due under the law
administered by the secretary shall not
be assigned will accept extent
specifically authorized by law and such
payments made to or on account of a
beneficiary shall be exempt from
taxation shall be exempt from claim of
creditors and shall be liable to
attachment Levy seizure or any other
legal or equitable process whatsoever
either before or after receip of
beneficiary that's PL in day all we need
to do at your level is Implement what
has already been written most recently
May 15 2017 the Supreme Court affirmed
all veteran benefits have been protected
by 38 USC 5301 devastating the indirect
challenges under property States cannot
courts cannot vest that which under
Government Federal Law they lack the
authority to give that clears up Mr
Fraser's story about his benefit that
comes back from the federal funding how
their Patty Pockets using our money mind
you your money cuz you pay me you pay
every veteran who receives this benefit
so what you would like to think is this
so the government take taxpayers dollars
pay a disabled veteran such as myself
and turn around and take the money to
give someone an award for child support
that's counterproductive and it also
will leave me homeless or commit suicide
you can Google all you got your phones
present I like you to Google how many
veterans are killing themselves
daily that went through my War era and
maybe because of Reason such as this I
contemplated suicide several points to
this process tired of fighting I've been
in that War I made it back home safe 22
years later my government now says Mr
Thomas we're going to help take care of
you and then I have to fight again out
of a 70% award by the federal government
the courts was asking for
$571 for one child when all my other
children was grown out of $1,400 a month
please tell me could anyone in this
panel live offer the $800 indifference
if I had to pay the $571 and that money
was exempt has been exempt it's been
clear there should not even be a
discussion at legislative body in your
state discussing what this is what we
need to do is simply implement the rules
that's already there 38 USC 5301 38 USC
5307 which is a pment which equates to
garnishment okay because in theory what
you would be simply saying it's okay to
take the federal government that is
being given to me to take care of me
because I can't take care of myself
that's absurd totally absurd and the
think that American soldiers this what
we went to fight for come back home and
have to fight again it's appalling it is
it's AET nine and soldiers are killing
themselves probably due to this cause
I'm talking to my friends and my
brothers every day online throughout
this country this is not just a problem
in New Hampshire it's a problem
throughout the country the thing that
gets me is the child support department
of revenue here St by the state
understand this federal government
program through Social Security okay
allocated funds every year being matched
by what the veterans money that been
given us by taxpayers that's a ripoff
somebody is doing an injustice much less
with the taxpayer dollar but they also
turn around they taking it back and
patting their own Pockets because if
through dispersement that so-called
judge that's sitting there that's a fake
judge not a
title Thomas Mr Thomas you're getting
you're getting a little off course Mr
Thomas we're we're here on uh House Bill
1716 you're getting a little off course
now I'm apologize I'm emotional but no
need to apologize just here's a cut
through title 38 already secures the
veterans benefit very good okay Congress
Supreme Court ruling May 15 2017 already
took the powers from these courts to do
what they're doing to Veterans the
proper protocol when it comes with
there's a guideline very simply says
when a a veteran comes before the court
there's four simple little rules you
first you you you decide is the VOR my
DD214 proves that does I receive any
benefit from the uh government there's
my award letter and then it also tells
you the portion that there's that waret
that goes off the table can't be used
for numeration of income Mr Frasier
would like to allude to that in the
numeration in the CFR 45 it would
stipulate that veterans disability
compensation is part of that award no it
is not it can't be utilized it's a play
on words the other thing that I like my
brothers if they're listening all you
need to please stop calling what you
receive as income because it's not
income it's disability compensation it's
a term used for the pra you look up
Black's Law I don't work again could
could could we get back on the subject
matter which is H spill
1716 did this this is what we're here
hear mandated by your state and your
legislative body to everybody read 38
USC 5301 yes we heard that through
everybody's testimony
y yes and then also just go look at the
Supreme Court ruling of May 15 2017 this
has already been done thank you it's
already been done because the courts
need to start following it at the state
local level very good thank you Mr
Thomas do we uh the panel the committee
have any questions for Mr
Thomas seeing none thank you Mr Thomas
thank you
uh so I don't see any other um attendees
wanting to testify
Christina no um one is already testified
and one is an unidentified number okay
very good uh so at this time I'll close
uh I'll close the hearing on House Bill
1716 and we'll um open the we'll open
the hearing on Senate Bill
um I'll call on Cameron I
iine yes I do see that representative
rice has her hand up if you wanted to
recognize her if you wanted to go
representative rice no she's she's put
it down okay so hearing on Senate Bill
uh Miss
iine hello yes hi hi hi this is Cameron
leine I am the legislative Aid assigned
to Senator Carson Senator Carson had to
hop on another call at this point um and
asked me to introduce Senate Bill 295 FN
on her behalf this bill Rec codifies the
statutes governing the office of the
child advocate clarifi the authority and
Independence of the office and expands
the jurisdiction of the office to
include a broader range of agencies that
serve children this bill also
establishes an oversight Commission on
children's services and I respectfully
uh refer any questions to people who
will testify after me thank you very
good thank you Miss
leine
um I I uh I don't have that
list more than happy to help out yeah I
know you emailed it to me i' have to
look it up again right I've got 200
emails since then yes let's take a look
I do have um Ken Norton um from Nami
Hampshire uh chair recognizes Mr Norton
see if I can if he's still on yep here
he
is he's uh
muted oh there we
go yeah Mr Norton you're we can hear
you I'm not sure if you can hear me yes
we can hear
you I can no longer hear you
maybe that's what it is okay that's what
it is because we could certainly hear
you if you can hear me just nod and I'll
go ahead and give my testimony okay um
thank you uh chairman long committee
members my name is Ken Norton I'm the
executive director of Nami New Hampshire
the national Lance on mentalness I'm
also a a former foster parent and I'm an
adoptive parent through
dcyf and I'm a licensed independent
clinical social worker in New Hampshire
and I'm here to strongly support Senate
Bill
295 um the um during the short tenure of
the office of child advocate they've
really in uh demonstrated um a level of
Independence and integrity and
transparency to hold us all as a state
collectively accountable for making
needed improvements in our um child
protective and Juvenile Justice
System the um and based on my own
personal and professional experience
I think that the that our families and
vulnerable children um often um don't
operate in isolation to specific systems
and many kids and families are caught in
gaps and barriers between systems and we
see that all the time um at Nami New
Hampshire through our information
resource line and and some of the work
that we do with families and I think
that it's not just um children and
families that get caught it is um some
of our really knowledgeable and
effective and caring service providers
they're unable to proceed with what
would be most helpful for um a
vulnerable child and family because of
these systems barriers and gaps um and
we've seen firsthand I've seen firsthand
the effectiveness of the office of child
advocate to investigate um assess and
make recommendations relative to
promoting cross systems Co collaboration
and resolution on challenging issues
that are faced um by children and
families and I believe that expanding
the reach of the office of child
advocate um as included in this law to
include suicide and psychological injury
and risk and other critical incidents um
that are listed in the in the bill many
with um you know with certainly mental
health impacts and Trauma um with them
and um and will be really helpful I also
believe it's consistent with the goal of
the 10-year mental health plan from
January
2019 and um specifically the the
recommendations relative to coordinated
Continuum of Care and uh and that
particular part of the plan talks about
the integration of the Department of
Health and Human Services and other
state agencies um the system of care the
governor's Commission on alcohol school
safety um preparedness and and other
things and I think that the office of
child advocate would be very helpful in
um in bringing those different systems
together and providing that level of
accountability um and um and connection
that is is needed and then lastly I
would just say that I think it's
particularly important as we look toward
the the vulnerability of Children and
Family relative to the covid environment
that we're in and the budget pressures
that are sure to follow and uh certainly
are going to have severe impacts on our
children and families um so Nami New
Hampshire strongly believes this
legislation can dramatically improve the
safety net for children and families in
New Hampshire and I I thank you for your
time and I would take questions but I'm
not sure if I can hear
you uh can you can you hear me uh Mr
Norton he can't here for some reason so
uh well uh I know representative
Connor's had a question but he's not
able to hear us that's okay my question
was just for the first speaker to repeat
their Nam so I could have it for the
record oh Ken Norton no the prior one
who introduced that was that was uh
staff um Cameron
leine Cameron leine Cameron leine yes
thank you thank you uh
so I
I only see one other hand one other hand
up to testify and and that's
representative Horgan is that no we have
uh three others that that
registered okay is uh representative
Oregan uh he did I believe he may have
um later on okay I just got wiped out
here so I don't
um okay so
uh I do have a James buffetti I have a
James buffetti uh associate Ag
Department of Justice uh Mr
buffetti I don't have no members of
public listed to testify on this hello
you
okay goad Mr buffetti yes can you hear
me yes good afternoon uh Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
James buffetti I'm an associate attorney
general and um so I'm hoping that the
letter that we sent in on February to
the chairman has made its way to the
committee uh it um highlights the
concerns that the Department of Justice
has with this
legislation I'm testifying in opposition
uh but I don't want that to detract in
any way uh from the important and
critical work that the office of the
child advocate does every day and we
support that uh there are there is some
language in that bill that creates some
um significant concern having to do with
uh accountability uh and
oversight so uh primarily there's
language in the bill that says the
office shall notwithstanding any other
provision of law operate with full
independence from any state official
department or agency in the performance
of its
duties that language uh as uh if if
properly understood would uh remove any
accountability and oversight for the
child advocate even from the governor
and the Attorney General um as as you
know under our system executive power is
vested in the governor who was elected
um by the people to uh to uh uh Faith to
make sure that the laws are Faithfully
executed um this agency is an executive
branch agency uh in addition the
Attorney General is the chief law
enforcement officer and has statutory
authority to make sure that all
executive branch agencies and officers
perform their duties according to the
law uh that's very important to make
sure that uh we continue to be in
compliance with the law that we we that
we minimize litigation risks against the
state um and um and finally judges and
courts um are charged with with
resolving disputes but if you read that
language
literally uh it's suggesting that the
office of child advocate would be exempt
from those provisions of law from the
Executive Branch from the attorney
generals and from the courts which is
fundamental to our system of government
uh so we have been raising this issue uh
for quite a while now since 2019 when
this bill was first uh brought forward
in the in the Senate um in a sense this
language would create the office of
child advocate as an unaccountable
fourth branch of government uh and it
raises concerns uh I think there are
ways there is language that we can make
sure that that office is uh independent
and can do the critical work that it has
to do without at the same time uh in
putting into a statute language that is
contrary to the Constitution and
contrary to concept of good
government um there are other issues
that are in the letter that I hope that
you'll have a chance to look at U the
bill does entrust the office of child
advocate with Broad and unfed discretion
to for example investigate the actions
of any agency any agency in the state um
investigate and issue subpoenas relating
to any media report of a child that's
the standard if uh if there was a media
report uh regarding a child the this
bill would give the child advocate the
authority to issue
subpoenas um and finally uh we rais an
issue about access to autopsy reports uh
and in some cases autopsy reports uh
that involved homicides um and the
problem with the language is that the
that the bill would permit uh the office
of child advocate to disclose
confidential information contained in a
homicide autopsy report um without any
uh check by the Department of Justice
that provision has the potential to
jeopardize sensitive criminal
investigations and in fact could impinge
on a defendant's right to a fair
trial that's my testimony Mr chairman
I'm happy to answer
questions thank you attorney buetti are
there any
questions I don't see any questions from
the committee uh I do representative
jerus thank you I'm sorry I I could
digitally raise my hand fast enough um
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chair um I'm wondering so is
there um the language that you were
concerned about at the beginning about
you said almost establishing a a fourth
branch of government um is that
something that you see could be uh
remedied by moderately simple amendment
is there a simple language change that
you would see that could make it so that
we're not that there's still some
Independence but it's not completely
unaccountable to any branch of
government oh I'm I'm sure there's ways
of doing that and you know we've we've
of I don't have language today to
propose but I I I think if the intent is
that we want this office to be
independent in that it can investigate
uh state agencies for instance dcyf if
there's an issue and that's what that's
what this office is doing so well now uh
that they should be able to do that and
have the independence to do that um this
language simply goes too far uh because
uh of of the reasons that I stated
before thank
you uh representative
Baran representative Baran you're a
sponsor co-sponsor on this bill are you
I just I'm just point of
information um I haven't seen I haven't
seen the letter has that been
distributed well that's the question I
was going to ask him once the committee
had all questioned out and we have uh so
Mr beet you said that I received a
letter in
February uh yes Mr chairman I I mailed
it in February February 27th it's dated
but when I responded uh requested to
testify uh to to this hearing today I
also attached it to the email that I
sent so it should be there if not I'm
I'm happy to resend it to you okay uh so
you emailed it to the committee or uh so
there was an email address that I that I
needed to respond to in order to
officially request to testify today yeah
yeah and I attached it as a HTS okay so
they could they could get that letter
out to us okay very good thank you sir
you're wel uh actually representative
question representative horn thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question sir uh
has there
been any
difficulties with the AG and the office
of the child advocate exchanging
[Music]
information um well the we've we uh we
actually represent the office of child
advocate so we have an attorney here who
works closely with the office um so the
information wouldn't be exchanged
between us and and and the office uh
usually the information that she's
looking for would be information from
dcyf and from other social agencies I
don't think there's been a problem I do
think that that there may be cases where
we need to provide legal guidance we're
we're we're obligated to do that with
not only that executive agency but every
agency so we provide attorneys who are
essentially client counselors who work
with agencies to make sure that the
agencies are complying with with law and
so issues come up about right to know
questions and Personnel issues and other
issues that we will work with all our
clients with to make sure that we are
minimizing risk of litigation we would
do the same thing with the office of
child advocate as we would do with every
other state
agency uh followup representative thank
you Mr chairman I'm reminded of the
passage in the Bible that says a man
cannot serve two masters and I'm
wondering if
if there are situations where there
would be a conflict of interest where
the office of the child advocate is
asking questions of
DCF but because they're in the Office of
the Attorney General they can DCF can
claim client privilege against answering
them because they're being represented
by DCF by uh AG
attorneys so we we oftentimes have uh
have clients on different sides of of of
issues
uh we would have a separate attorney who
would be working with the office of
child advocate from attorneys that would
be working with the Department of Health
and Human Services and DCF so we because
we're called on to represent every state
agency we would we would separate out
lawyers who could represent the and will
represent the office of child advocate
they will not be involved with
Al so representative another followup
representative horn thank you Mr
chairman sorry about that um so even if
we move the office of the child advocate
out from underneath the Attorney
General's office you would continue to
represent them as they're an executive
branch
office the bill wouldn't this bill
wouldn't change that
situation thank you for your question
representative actually the office of
child advocate is not a part of the
Attorney General's office so I if I was
I I was understood to to say that I I I
apologize that's not what I was saying
what I was saying is that every state
every executive branch
agency uh is is supervised by Statute by
law by the Attorney General to make sure
that they're performing their duties
according to the law so every agencies
meaning the the Department of Safety and
the Department of Transportation the
office of child advocate we uh we work
with every agency uh to make sure that
they are complying with the law but but
but the office of child advocate is not
a part of the Department of Justice in
in the sense I think you you minut
it uh representative
Coda thank you chair um thank you
attorney
buff um
I have seen the in the past last year
the ability of committees in an office
like um child advocate having the
authority to um do subpoenas when
necessary do do they come to the
Attorney General's office to ask for
Counsel on such things or do they are
they able to work within the law to um
determine the appropriateness of
that so the statute doesn't require them
to come to us um they certainly can and
a lot of state agencies who have
subpoena power that's given by the
legislature uh will want to consult with
us because sometimes legal issues come
up um but they're not required to do so
uh and uh but we are certainly here to
assist um the office of child advocate
if they have questions like that and
want us to to help them with it
wonderful thank
you uh representative
yella yes thank you and thank you for
taking my question um so you have uh
multiple attorneys that would be able to
um represent each side without having a
conflict and is it also your position
that you have no um oversight role
currently on the uh
Office of the child
advocate No in
fact so no in fact if you uh if you look
at RSA 21 colon
3B uh that's the statute that says that
the attorney general has the authority
to ensure that all executive branch
agencies and officers perform their
duties according to the law so it's from
that from that uh perspective by law
that we are supposed to that is what
we're supposed to be doing here uh
provide guidance uh because uh part of
it is to avoid problems you know we we
we work with clients to to to minimize
litigation risks you know this office
especially is dealing with high-profile
very difficult cases and so we want to
make sure that we minimize any
litigation risk for the state in all
agencies and we do that by being
proactive with attorneys who are client
act as client counselors for the state
agencies and we regularly uh interact
with them on a daily basis to make sure
that we answer their questions and
assist them uh and then if the state
gets sued then we would represent the
state in defending those actions so but
the goal is to prevent the state from
getting sued in the first instance and
we do that by exercising the statutory
uh very good uh uh representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you very
much for taking my question I'm I'm
harking back to the very beginning of
your testimony when you said you
expressed your concern with the language
on page two lines 25 and 26
notwithstanding any other provision of
law they shall operate with full
independence from any state official or
agency um I read that as me Independence
but was I understanding you to say that
you are interpreting that to actually
put this uh office Above the Law because
that's not the way it reads to
me uh so yes uh the the concern is that
again not withstanding any other
provision of law operate with full
independence from any state official
including the governor and the Attorney
General any state department or agency
in the performance of its duties so um
where is the
accountability uh I mean we're all
accountable to somebody ultimately um so
where is the
accountability uh if it's an executive
agency the accountability is to the
governor and to the attorney
general followup Mr chairman uh followup
thank you sir and thank you again for
taking my second question uh but my
understanding I is it not true that if
we remove that then it's not only
accountability that we're
removing and and and as I read it you
still have accountability but if you
remove that language then either the
Attorney General's office or the
governor can simply tell the office of
child advocate what they're going to do
and how they're going to do it and the
point here is to have somebody who is
independent of
that
uh political
influence
um but certainly not above the
law but I think that's just the point
representative I think that it it has
the potential of being interpreted as
putting this office Above the Law
because it's not only the attorney
general and the governor but the courts
uh if they're completely independent
from any state official meaning a judge
uh then again uh we need to have
accountability and oversight uh of of
executive
agencies uh which means that we need to
let them do their work uh but but our
system of government is a system of
accountability and checks and balances
and uh and we have to have a way to to
say you're an executive branch official
and as all executive branch official
then the executive power uh of the of
the state government is vested in the
governor who is elected by the people
and charged with the faithful execution
of
laws okay thank you uh would you be
willing to provide some alternative
language that you're more comfortable
with that
preserves what you think needs to be
preserved while preserving to the
maximum extent possible the independence
of this
agency uh I I'd be happy to work with
and we've offered this along the way
offer to happy to work with the
committee with the office of child
advocate uh to see if we can find
language that uh that addresses the
Independence that they clearly need to
do their job but doesn't create a fourth
branch of government thank
you uh very good any uh I don't see any
other questions from uh the Comm
uh thank you sir you're welcome thank
you very much have a good day and uh I
believe the final person requesting to
testify is MOA
O'Neal we have MOA O'Neal and we also
okay were you
recognizing yes here we
go she's uh muted right
now oh there we oh you had her for a
minute she's still
muted can you hear me now yes hello
thank you good afternoon um chairman
long and vice chair Baran thank you so
much for um giving your time to Senate
Bill 295 relative to the office of the
child advocate this afternoon and
congratulations on uh managing through
the technology for this sort of
historical uh day of hearings it's great
to be a part of it I want to thank
Senator Carson representative rice and
representative Baran who are co-sponsors
on this bill um I'll try to be um a
brief you have my written testimony um
but I'll Focus essentially on the two uh
major adjustments that Senate Bill 295
does for the child advocate statute
which are to make Services comprehensive
and equitably accessible for children
and also to clarify the independence as
you've just heard um some discussion
already ready um and I'll also point out
um thanks to uh Ken Norton who mentioned
the impending pressures of covid-19 and
the budget issues that we see ahead um
and remind you that the very existence
of the office of the child advocate was
born out of a period of user budget
actions that resulted in really
untenable tragedy so it's taken us a
decade to get mamire back on track in
just building an infrastructure for
supporting children so the role of the
office of the child Advocate is very
important so the two main um adjustments
that we're seeing first the expanding
services for the office of the child
advocate the the Crafters of the
founding legislation to establish this
office looked to Massachusetts for a
model um but they stopped short at
endowing the office with the breadth of
jurisdiction that Massachusetts has and
my understanding is that they
anticipated a phased approach in order
to avoid over overwhelming a brand new
office facing a child welfare system in
crisis um the current Massachusetts
child advocate Maria mades explained why
broad jurisdiction is important to us
recently she said and I quote children
and their families require support from
a wide range of State services including
education in order to grow into a
healthy adulthood so in Massachusetts
the OCA is the only agency that looks
across all state services to identify
the gaps and opportunities to ensure
that children have what they need to
thrive so I I I reminded that um and we
should all be reminded that the office
actually has no enforcement Authority
the only Power and means of being
effective is in access to information
and the privilege to review that
information to better inform all of the
parties involved with helping a child so
expanding the jurisdiction is really
only expanding access to children's
stories often the points of intersection
where State systems meet are where
children's needs are most effective so
the Connecticut child advocate Sarah
Egan also echoed what Moses had had had
pointed out which is quote having access
to information across state systems that
serve children is absolutely essential
to understanding how vulnerable
children's need s are met or not through
state funded services so virtually every
report the office of the child advocate
in Connecticut does including fatality
investigations looks across systems so
that they can truly understand how
children's health safety and Welfare are
supported and protected so both of those
Advocates are pointing out a
fundamentally important view of the
functions of these office they're
describing not how well agencies are
functioning
they're describing how well children are
served so if children are served by more
than one agency we can't fully
understand where the gaps are if we only
examine a single agency's
involvement and Egan and Connecticut
provided a really good and and and um
sad example of a child fatality in
Connecticut um involving a child who had
autism intellectual disability was
chronically missing from school and was
subject of a neglect petition prior to
his death so he was known by the school
system the courts the legal system the
health providers and Child Protection as
a child who needed help and protection
by accessing information across all
those involved state funded systems the
Connecticut OCA was able to see the gaps
and how they contributed to the
circumstances that led to that boy's
death and I've given you a citation and
and a link to the report on that child's
stas so this example is one that's
consistent with actually the findings
and recommendations of all of our
reports to date um that show the
necessity for
interprofessional understanding and
communication across all entities
serving children so it's best to meet
their needs so expanding the office uh
offices jurisdiction to cover all state
Services provided to children it's fair
it's thorough it's efficient and it's
forward thinking because right now state
and federal initiatives are shifting
emphasis from responding to child abuse
to preventing it so the heft of State
Investments is right now moving upstream
and it makes more sense to have this
independent eye on the development and
the implementation of programs intended
to be responsive to Children's needs we
know that few children start out in the
care and supervision of dcyf and we need
to be able to help before they get to
that point and to Monitor and support
dcyf when they do so through access to
information the office of the child
advocate is able to inform the
development and implementation of policy
and practice as it's experienced by
children and families themselves it's
been really valuable when we've had the
opportunity to um provide information in
that way this is a really powerful
feedback loop for ensuring the best
interests of children are served and
we've also seen
in the um covid-19 pandemic um that
underscores the need for an expanded
ability to help children because right
now under the current statute we're able
to assess the care of only 10 children
in residential care who are covid-19 U
positive infected um and in my written
testimony I note that it's eight but
it's actually 10 that we know of about
at this point um we know that there are
actually more children than 10 who have
the covid-19 infection
but because they were placed in
residential programs by their schools we
don't have access to their records and
we can't help them or advocate for them
similarily as as Ken Norton had
suggested when a parent calls us
desperate for mental health services
we're going to do our best to provide
information to them but we can't unless
they're involved with dcyf we can't
examine where's a child coming from
what's been tried what's going on at
schools what developmental services are
they receiving in order to identify
those gaps that will help um rectify the
distress that both the parent and the
child have reached at the point that
they've contacted us so expanding
jurisdiction would allow us to assist
families before abuse before neglect
before delinquency
occurs then the independent issue that
um that you were just hearing about from
Mr
buetti Senate Bill 295 clarifies the
office is independent So currently the
statute
reads that the office shall be an
independent agency so Independence is
just assumed it's essential to The
credibility of the office in order to
enjoy the trust with citizens it must be
free from undue influence and conflict
of interest or even the appearance of
that this key ingredient to credibility
has been questioned in several ways and
you've just heard some of those question
questions so first the independence of
the office was it was called into
question due to an appearance that it's
part of the Department of Health and
Human Services in other words we're part
of the problem and that perception is
remedied by moving the office to its own
statute now the enabling statute was
legislated in a budget Bill and because
of that the language wasn't thorough so
there are no definitions for example so
the definitions clarify the role scope
and authority of the office and Sen Bill
295 includes a full list of responsive
definitions including definitions of
critical incidents and the critical
incidents that the rep that the
department is required already to report
to us about actually includes by dcf's
definitions media reports so they're not
media reports about any child but it's a
but they're media reports that DCF is
looking at because a child is injured or
there's a child Fatality and that's in
the news and there's a concern about
that in terms of child protection and
child welfare because when a child is in
the news there can be very negative
repercussions on that child's life and
experience and their siblings or any
other children who are involved and that
is explained in the section of the
definitions um there's also been
challenges to the office's Independence
in relation to the Office of the
Attorney General um and while we have
confidence and have been informed that
the attorney General takes every measure
to separate representation of state
agencies as Mr buffetti has just
explained the perception of a conflict
persists and representative Horn's
Biblical reference to a man serving two
masters is implicated here so despite
the Attorney General's effort to
separate interest the Attorney General
is inherently embedded in DCF by its
involvement in supervising training and
supporting DCF attorneys conducting RSA
126 U investigations of children in DCF
custody when they are seriously injured
or or killed during a restraint they
participate in DCF special case reviews
and they also participate in many DCF
operational meetings it's very rare that
we attend meetings with DCF that the
Attorney General is not represented the
remedy to the appearance or perception
of compromised Independence borrows
language from other States offices of
the child Advocates so that line 25 in s
SP 295 that proposes the language not
withstanding any other provision of the
law operate with full independence from
any state official department or agency
in the performance of its duties is
language that is taken from other um
other offices
including Connecticut which has been in
existence for over 25 years Rhode Island
I think has been existence for about 35
years Massachusetts as well and we give
you the citations to those
laws this language separates the office
from any other agency including the
Attorney General so long as its agents
operate in compliance with the law so Mr
bietti's concerns that the office would
be exempt from provisions of law are in
this way unfounded any deviation from
lawful performance of duties would
warrant usual oversight of the Attorney
General the governor any member of
executive Council or the oversight
Commission on children's
services so I've addressed some of the
issues that that Mr Buffet's mentioned
um I I want to point out criminal acts
do not fall within the lawful
performance of Duties in the office of
the child advocate another concern of
his expresses that um that the office
would operate without any oversight in
fact Senate Bill 295 recodified
oversight Commission on children's
services that's currently operating
under RSA 170
g19 it's a multi-disciplinary commission
with representation from all branches of
government the oversight commission
provides oversight of the office of the
child advocate furthermore the director
is appointed by the governor for a Tim
limited appointment the time limit is
viewed as a protection against overreach
But ultimately RSA chapter 41 empowers
the Attorney General the governor any
member of the executive Council or the
appointing authority for That official
to petition the governor and councel to
remove the director for cause they these
are very clear and effective mechanisms
of oversight designed to endorse
confidence in prevention of corruption
or unlawful Behavior but also assuring
the independence necessary for an
effective voice voice on behalf of
children as the first director of The
Office of the child advocate I really
feel the weight of ensuring the office
is well grounded and able to function as
the legislature envisioned for the long
run as an independent agency Senate two
Senate Bill 295 refines and positions
the office for Independence for
impartiality for credibility and for
privilege to access that necessary
information to make a difference in how
effectively children are served by the
state of New Hampshire there are other
small adjustments in the current statute
um I want to especially call your
attention to the Senate amendment that
removed the fiscal note on this bill um
and then just a couple of quick comments
on um on a couple of other things that
came up in Mr Buffet's testimony um his
reference to the office of the child
advocate having the authority to
investigate any agency it's the office
of the child advocate and in the
definitions and in the main statute um
this is referring to any agency that
serves children and it wouldn't be in
the normal performance of duties for
example that the child advocate would
investigate um uh some state agency that
doesn't serve children at all that
wouldn't make any sense so it is
definitely limited to um to the agencies
that are serving children and generally
what prompts this Authority is when
there are complaints received or the
child advocate identifies where children
are not served properly I've already
explained to you about the media reports
and then um I'll stop here and take any
other questions that you might have
thank you so much for this
opportunity thank you uh Miss O'Neal
uh representative French you have a
question uh yes I would thank you for
allowing me to ask a question chair and
Dr O'Neal thank you for taking my
question um I understood you to say that
the fiscal note has been removed by the
Senate yes thank you for that question
the the fiscal the fiscal note attach
was um was the need for additional
positions and in the last session um the
the both the Senate and the house uh
made accommodations for two new
positions in the office so um so we are
we are fully staffed or or we are we are
situated to be fully staffed so it's not
necessary and it was removed um when it
was inste at
Judiciary thank
you representative
horn thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for coming to give your testimony it's
always enjoyable to listen to the source
of
expertise um my question concerns the
oversight committee establishing by my
count 18 separate people who would be
appointed by various authorities to
impanel this oversight commission um do
you have any concerns about a 18 people
or be the Quorum requirement to be nine
people um thank you for that question I
hadn't really given thought to uh
concerns about Quorum because generally
the oversight commission meetings are
well attended um and it is actually um
enlarged in Senate Bill 295 because it's
made room for two new positions one
being a foster parent and one being
someone who has in their past received
Services as a child from DCF we agreed
with Senator Carson that that was
important that people who are consumers
of um dcyf services and and state
services in general um could really give
us good guidance um from the oversight
commission um so um I I don't I think
that New Hampshire generally tends to
have very large committees anyhow um it
includes a lot of folks and so we're
sort of used to that I don't think 18 is
ungainly um and we always really
appreciate very very substantive
feedback from the the oversight
Commission on the work that we do I I
regret that it's a public committee and
it's not or commission and it's not
something that acts more as an advisory
panel because I think we could benefit
from that a little bit more and having
private conversations um but we have
found the oversight commission to be
really useful and we we' had good
feedback about um our ability to take um
guidance and instruction from them as
well thank
you very good seeing uh no more no more
questions uh thank you Dr O'Neal thank
you uh I have two more people to speak
I'll call uh next up
dejoy just a moment okay up
here oh there you are there we go Mr Joy
and I assume people can hear me yes
thank you very much and and members of
the committee I I'm going to do my best
to be brief I appreciate your
perseverance through this afternoon I
can see a lot of tired faces and I don't
want to do anything to add to that um
you have my testimony I will I will try
to excerpt it as I go through it and I
always hate when I have to follow Dr
O'Neal with her testimony because she
ends up stealing most of my testimony
and yet again today she has taken most
of my testimony and I'll try to skip
those parts just one clarification in
terms of the fiscal note the fiscal note
uh the Senate cannot remove the fiscal
note there is still a fiscal note but it
has no application now as she pointed
out it was request for two positions
that were approved through the budget
and so there is no reference to any need
for financing in the bill and we expect
Finance would uh decline to take this
bill uh to the the
committee
um the the second point I would make is
that this originally was a standalone
Bill several years ago and was on this
committee heard the bill and it was only
uh combined with the budget after the
policy committee had acted on the policy
and forwarded it so the reason it may
not be as robust in the the current
language has more to do with my
shortcomings than it does with the
shortcomings of the legislative process
um so most of you are aware of this most
of you have been dealing with this for a
number of years and are aware this
committee approved the bill three years
ago thus creating the office of the
child
advocate when I brought this language to
you three years ago I made a statement
such to the effect that we um were
providing a very limited scope of
oversight so as not to overwhelm the
office but we fully expected we would be
back asking for expanded oversight as it
was warranted and that's really what
this bill does today before you in in
the main it expands the scope of the
office uh Beyond uh dcyf which is
primarily where the scope has been uh
years the expanded scope will include as
uh Dr O'Neal said child child services
uh child serving agencies but will also
include contracted Services uh and most
particularly will include doe uh there
are a number of schools that provide
services and schools are far beyond the
oversight um of the office and in fact
what we should permit the and expect the
office to do is follow the data where it
leads not be stopped at a border of an
agency when data suggests that there may
be some reason to to take a look at that
agency we should allow the data to to
speak to the office and and follow the
data where it uh uh where it
leads so just very briefly some history
for folks who were not on the committee
three years ago who were not involved in
in this legislation several years ago um
this office really had its Beginnings
after the Great Recession back in 2009
2010 at that point we had significant
budget short
Falls budget cuts were made across the
board and few of any agencies were uh
were unaffected by those budget cuts DCF
was particularly affected by those
budget
cuts and during the ensuing years were
some of the most difficult days for DCF
it's when we saw the case loads explode
it's when we saw a lack of workers it's
when we saw a lack of services it's when
we saw the department
um de facto changed the definition of
abuse and neglect which has now been
codified so that fewer um fewer children
were able to access the services uh that
were available leaving more families uh
to fend for
themselves it was in fact the deaths of
multiple children in the in the 2014
2015 era that prompted the the
commissions that ultimately recommended
creating this office
I bring that up uh not simply to talk
about history but to tie it to today
today with the covid crisis we are also
seeing currently about $135 million
shortfall in state budget revenues we we
are already assured that the next budget
cycle will be quite difficult and there
will be cuts across the board again next
year we have just dug out of the hole
that we created for ourselves a number
of years ago and in order to protect
children this office is a very important
part of that and will be an essential
part of that as we move forward through
the next budget I apologize for my cat
um this office will be essential to to
stay above political considerations and
only look at what is in the best
interest of children and I think and for
that reason um among the others you've
heard is a reason to make sure this
office exists
but exists in full Independence uh there
is robust oversight as you heard and um
Dr O'Neal I know has provided you with a
list of the the um the oca's
Publications for the past couple of
years I would encourage you to take a
look at it it is a substantial list
showing the work they have done um and
there is far more work that that they
will be able to do over the next several
years um with that I would simply ask
you to support the bill um and to expand
the scope of the office thank you thank
you Mr de Joy are there any questions
from the committee I don't see any so
thank you Mr The Joy uh the the uh final
um is uh I need to speak with um
Christina is he able to speak with us
yes somebody who couldn't register I
guess okay uh Giles Binet Giles Binet
okay very good Mr Binet here we
go hi can everyone hear me yes oh great
and I'm not I'm not sure if I'm on video
as well but I'd be happy to to have
video if if that's what the committee
prefers it's whatever you prefer we're
we're good okay well I actually would
like to have video so let's see if I can
do it for
okay um bear with me for one moment I'm
trying to get my computer up up
here or I don't know if the moderator
has the ability
to to turn my video yeah I don't see you
in the uh oh I do see you yeah there's
no video access under your
moment hi am I can I be viewed now yes
sir you can oh good thank you so much my
apologies for um the tech issues um my
name is y b I'm the legal director for
the ACLU of New Hampshire thank you so
much for the opportunity to testify I'll
try to keep this as brief as possible
recognizing that we are close towards
the end of the the the day um this is a
bill uh that the ACLU supports read
recommend that this bill be voted out of
committee ought to pass uh because we
think it's critical for uh the office of
the child advocate to be independent in
order to ensure that it can adequately
protect children and perform
its government accountability function
without undue pressure um I am aware I'm
going to really limit my testimony to
the legal constitutional and separation
of powers issues raised by the Attorney
General's office um I am aware that the
Department of Justice did submit a
letter with their concerns we yesterday
submitted a letter addressing the
Attorney General's concerns and our
belief that those concerns are unfounded
I do hope that the committee received
that letter if it did not I'd be happy
to circulate it individually uh to to
all the members um but I would just say
really at I really want to make three
points and and number one is just how
Independence is really essential and
necessary in this case um and it's
essential and necessary because the work
of the office of the child advocate is
inherently going to be intention in
ention and adverse to DCF and
potentially other state agencies and so
now you have a situation where you have
two agencies that have conflicting
interests
potentially um and Independence is
essential
because if you have the Department of
Justice say
representing uh or managing both
entities there is a potential conflict
one could imagine that conflict
obviously occurring if the OCA wants to
issue a subpoena understandably so to
DCF for documents and so that is why I
think it is so critical that the OCA
exist uh independently to really avoid
even the appearance of those types of
conflicts and to give the OCA the
independence and and uh free reign
without undue pressure it needs to to do
um its work um on point two on the
Constitutional issues um there is no
separation of powers problem with this
bill this bill does not um as the
Department of Justice say create an
unaccountable fourth branch of
government it does not do that and it
doesn't do that for several
reasons um and let me just say at the
outset I think the first reason is
because the office exists within the
executive branch we still have three
branches of government in New Hampshire
like the federal system the Judiciary
the executive branch um and the
legislature the OCA in this bill still
exists within the executive branch one
of the three branches of government um
here within I think it's the office of
administrative
services that is something that it is
perfectly appropriate for the
legislature to do uh but there is also
uh no separation of powers concerns here
because the OCA can and still be
effectively controlled or there is some
monum of control uh that the executive
branch here the governor has on the OCA
and I know that the the director talked
about some of these but I think it's
worth rearticulating the director can be
terminated um by the executive branch
for Mal feasance misfeasance
inefficiency in office etc those
Provisions are in rsa4 colon one which
are bootstrapped into this bill in
addition the Attorney General the
Governor or any member of the executive
Council can petition the governor in
Council for removal so the Attorney
General even if this bill were to
enacted uh to be enacted could actually
attempt to remove the director that is
um uh I think actually appropriate check
on the director's power um and I think
really blunts the department of
Justice's argument that that you know
this office really is just a fourth
branch unaccountable agency which it
clearly is not and then of course under
RSA 4.1 the director can ultimately then
be removed upon a vote by the governor
and executive
counsel in the federal context a lot of
these issues were actually
litigated um uh when there was a
challenge to the uh independent Council
statute uh this was a constitutional
challenge that went to the US Supreme
Court and that's a case called Morrison
versus old that was the independent
Council statute and the Supreme Court
said that there are adequate checks for
that independent Council to do its work
the independent Council needs to be
independent but there was enough
executive branch oversight um to uh to
eliminate any constitutional problems
it's exactly the scenario that we have
here with respect to um the OCA that is
to say the OCA and this bill are
constitutional really for all of the
same reasons that the independent uh
Council statute was constitutional in
Morrison over 30 years
ago um and also I think there's no
separation of power concern issue here
as well because the governor and
executive Council of course appoint the
OCA uh it's true that there's an
oversight commission that's tasked with
recommending the director of the OCA but
the bill does not require that the
governor and executive Council adopt
actually any of those recommended
candidates that's actually appropriate
in order to eliminate separate of powers
concerns and to eliminate any concern
that this could become a rogue
agency the third point I want to make um
and it relates to my introductory
remarks is that as a policy Choice the
legislature can give investig
investigatory powers to another
executive branch agency that's just not
the Department of Justice that's what
this bill is doing there are good
reasons to actually um embed these
Powers with a non-e department Justice
agency um I I won't get into the legal
analysis there of why that's appropriate
but it's something that certainly can be
done by Statute that is what this uh
this bill does and again to reiterate
it's embedding these investigatory
Powers within one of the three branches
of government the executive branch not
the not uh a a fourth Branch so with
that I'll conclude my testimony uh which
which I also U submitted last night
thank you very much very good uh we did
get your testimony thank you uh so any
questions um of Mr
Binet I don't see any so uh thank you Mr
Binet and I don't believe uh Christina
are there any others that I'm not seeing
that are willing to that are wanting to
testify I do not see any hands raised at
this point and everyone on the list has
testified very good so I'll close the
hearing on Senate Bill 295
and uh representative D Simon uh do you
still request the caucus you do so you
want to do uh it's five o'clock you want
to do 10 minutes we come back at um is
that enough time or yes I think so okay
so we'll come back at uh
510 thank you if everybody could just
make sure they mute and shut off the
on
okay
e
I wonder if we can read lips Republicans
that
all
hi
hello
uh okay being uh 510 I'll uh open the
executive session on House Bill 176
himself okay um on House Bill uh
study it second by uh representative
grman
and
discussion
deimon thank you Mr chair
um uh we are back from um our caucus and
um we definitely would not
um I'm not seeing anybody that wants
interim
discussion see none when when the uh
clerk is actually I got representative
horn thank you Mr chairman um I think my
big objection to interim study would be
along the lines of we heard plenty of
testimony today that there's something
um unjust about the system that's
currently in place and that maybe more
attention would be paid to the situation
if we have if we adopt HB
1716 um it would send a message I
believe that this is something that
needs attention that
uh while we may lack the statutory
authority to affect the Federal
standards um the federal standards are
obviously not working so rather than
interim study which in the covid-19
situation is unlikely to have anything
done on it um I would suggest that we
rice yes thank you um I I agree with
representative horn I don't think that
kicking this to the curb is the answer
um interim study is a polite death and I
just don't see I think this is something
that needs to be addressed
now thank you good and I I I don't see
this has kicken it to the curb uh has
representative horn said that maybe
something will happen I I'm not
comfortable with um with passing
supporting a bill that may do something
um
I in testimony the the emphasis was on
the state following the federal
guidelines we've heard of that uh and
um what was it there was a there was a
house bill that's addressing this this
standard uh the guideline standard which
appears to me would be the Avenue with
which this we would go I I'm
un I mean a lot of testimony was on
several
Federal uh Federal um statutes or
whatever they call them
um of which I I've been trying to get
answers to some of these and I I just
couldn't get them um you know I I had
questions that I couldn't get answered
so I don't feel that the passage of uh
House Bill
1716 is going to address it what it will
do is throw everything at a stir I and
I'm not I'm not prepared to support
something that that'll do that I don't
believe this passage helps the issue
that we're looking to address uh so
representative
yella thank you um I think that the what
the testimony showed us today is that
the
um more not so much the federal
guidelines but our specific custody or
child support formula is broken and that
we need to address that and that is
something that I think that um both
sides uh of this issue uh would support
moving forward with and so I think that
there is some appetite for trying to
address that issue in a
more holistic way I guess instead of
peac meiling trying to attack each
individual problem that the child
support formula creates and
so um as long as we're moving forward
with that issue um and trying to fix
that formula I think that um I think
we're on the right
path um I have a representative uh
Weber Mr chairman and thank you all for
your hospitality um I spent a certain
amount of time while we were listening
to testimony also reading some of the
federal statutes that were cited
and while my heart just
aches for the people who
are caught in this particular bind I
think that representative yella is
correct it needs to be looked at
globally if we just proceed with this
particular bill I do believe having
looked at it and I this is not the kind
of attorney I am I got to tell you um
and I'm long past my cell by date as an
attorney anyway uh but the federal
statute is talking about what you may do
not what you must do
and that's the one that they were citing
and the one that the um informational
message came out about and at the same
time there is the other statute that
does in fact require us to take all
income into account and so I think that
by trying to fix one specific problem
with this one specific Bill we are very
likely to get ourselves into a larger
mess and a larger morass that's going to
affect even more people so I think that
the the broader more Global look is is a
better way to go thank
you uh Christina I I just got a text uh
Cassie representative L is not able to
get back in for some reason I've got her
thank you she'll be in just a moment
very good representative
Baran yeah thank you um I I I I agree
with uh with representative yella and U
representative Weber um I in fact have
been working with um uh Brenda Town who
was a woman who spoke towards the end um
and explained about a group that she's
been working with and we've been working
together for about the last oh three or
four months to try and address some of
the issues around equal parenting and
she obviously is was concerned about
this this issue as well and um uh I
think that um expanding on the what what
should be the work of of
HB 362 in interim study is important and
um I've kind of agreed as most of you
know I'm going to be leaving the house
but um over the in the fall trying to
really work to um pull these various
threads together working with the and
also using the work that the
UNH um report had um to be able to come
together with some sort of comprehensive
com uh legislation for um that you all
can introduce next uh next
year so and I I that's why I'm going
with inter
study representative
deimon thank you Mr
chair I really think that it's time to
stop allowing people
um to live the way they're living
especially the
veterans this is a compensation that is
this is not
income these people are physically and
mentally injured for the rest of their
lives this money is not income it should
not be considered
income it is not federally tax
taxed therefore we we should vote to
pass this bill and get these veterans
back in society and give them their
money
back thank
you representative
horn Mr
chairman I
uh I know that in the past states have
taken up legislation when they feel that
uh an issue is important enough we
haven't seen a constitutional convention
in this country because if enough States
pass a certain type of legislation
Congress gets off their tases and passes
the amendments to the Constitution that
the states wanted in the first place so
we've never had a constitutional
convention for that specific reason I
feel strongly that by New Hampshire
sending a message that the federal
system that manages this affair isn't
protecting our veterans we give this
Congress the same opportunity to amend
the federal statutes to reflect what is
fair and what is just um there is a huge
difference between Social Security
disability and the Veterans Affairs
disability which is not being recognized
in the system at the point at this point
so I I would urge my colleagues to uh
consider voting no on is so that we can
adopt this legislation and send our our
delegation in Washington a signal that
hey pay attention to this because people
are dying because this is being
mismanaged thank you Mr
chairman representative
camarota thank you chairman committee
members in my short tenure I have seen
our
committee attend to small details of a
larger picture and pass the things with
the hope that next time we can add a
little bit more sometimes it's so big we
can't get just can't do it it gets too
convoluted so we do little and hope for
the best and then do a little bit more
I've seen that over and over again what
I saw today is something that I'm very
aware of and that is desperate
people are
veterans and the suicide
rate is an
incredible piece of data on Veterans and
to have these people come forward to us
saying they've been going through this
for
years is not acceptable there is no
reason that we can't do this one piece
to say we've got a serious problem and
we want the feds or we can do maybe
through uh
SB 362 or HB 362 maybe we can even do
better with that bill but this bill
should we should say no to is and we
should do a toath to help our veterans
they are desperate we we our hearts are
tugged when we talk about
children we're talking about our
veterans and they have done the most
incredible service for our country and
we need to help them and we need to help
them be fathers most of them were men to
their children which they kept saying
over and over I can't take care of my
child I I I have them for 60% of the
time I have them for 50% and I can't
have a one-bedroom I have to have a two
bedroom and that takes away from the
child it's absurd what we heard today so
I um agree with Deb and Warner I I say
no on is and it ought to ask thank
you representative
T panetti thank you Mr
Speaker I'm sorry as a substitute I
don't know if if um I'm allowed to speak
but I should speak as a
veteran um we heard the pain uh that
those veterans who
testified uh shared with us we saw one
of our own committee members um cry over
it um I have myself gone through this uh
about 35 40 years
ago
um there's not a whole lot of money that
these veterans receive that's counted
towards uh their total income that then
has to be taken out and given to child
support or
whatever however it's
dispensed it's very painful um and I'm
not an injured vet I don't get
disability um for them to um have to uh
live the life they have to live with a
disability with the money that comes out
and then uh and then use that money uh
not on their disability but for other
things like child support not that they
should they should definitely pay the
child support but the money issue is is
the the thing uh we heard them we heard
their we saw their pain uh we just I
don't think we can turn a cheek we've
got to do something yes um we probably
can't change it unless it change
federally but we can shout out very loud
to our federal delegate delegates that
this definitely needs to be
changed I believe interim study is the
is a bad thing to do it's kind of
turning the other cheek so my
recommendation would be to vote no in
inm study pass this send a message say
listen it's about time we change we have
to change this system this is wrong we
all know it's wrong you know it's wrong
I know it's wrong
so do the right thing and really send
the message to to the federal delegation
no on in study yes on OTP thank
Corson yeah thank you Mr chairman um I
find this incredibly difficult I've
taken care of these folks medically and
psychiatrically since
1976 I've taken care of them in Kentucky
and the coal mines I've taken care of
them in the emergency rooms of
Philadelphia Bost
I've taken care of folks uh in all kinds
of different environments who are the
folks that we have never treated well in
my experience over those 40 years they
have never received what they should be
receiving and we are trying to do
something on the top of something that
has been dismissed since n 1776 when we
wouldn't pay the people that fought the
Revolutionary War and this is more the
same and so where I get stuck is it
absolutely does need to change and I
don't see this bill changing it I see
this bill having us getting caught up in
trying to do something on the surface of
this problem that we just simply will
not as a country take care of the way we
should be taken care of and uh that
leads me to the conclusion that I would
not support the bill and I continue to
be
it's just hard to even know where to go
with what my own personal experiences
have been with hundreds thousands of
people though over these decades and
this is really disturbing but I can't
support
it uh representative right I thought I
saw your hand up here but I don't see
you anymore you're
okay okay so I'm sorry thank you um Mr
chairman um
so just so we're clear the federal aor
apportionment part of this is supposed
to be geared towards for the kids that's
why they get it so why are we taking
their other money and I do think we have
to send a
message because enough is enough I have
I'm so Furious that the court didn't
even give us the time to come here today
and address any of this with us they
have no accountability whatsoever and
it's time that we take the ball by the
horns and pass this bill not interim
study it needs to be OTP show these
veterans We Care I've had enough that's
where I'm at I forgive me for yelling
but this has been this was very
tired of hearing these stories I'm tired
of it and we have to fix it and I'm
voting a to pass I'm not voting for
you seeing uh seeing no more
questions I'll ask representative
Connors to uh call the RO uh the the
question is and I
believe uh one two three four five six
seven8 9 10 13 14 15 16 17
1920 we we have everybody uh everybody
here on the committee uh so
representative coners if you could do
you have a second do you have a
second representative camarado do we do
it was you have a second who was your
second it was moved by representative
you so representative con is the
question is on house Bill
1716 uh interim study thank you
representative
Baran he's got a thumbs up he's not able
to unmute himself yes
I representative
Mulligan
yes representative Connors is a yes
representative Corson
I was that an i yes thank you
representative Diggs
yes representative
French
no representative grman yes
patrino yes oh yes representative Weber
yes representative wiir
Simone absolutely
no representative rice no representative
horn no Representative camarota no
representative
Fowler hell
no Representative juus
no representative
yella yeah
yes Representative
panace
no chairman long
uh I'll open the executive session for
Senate Bill
295 I'm sorry Mr chairman yeah was that
a no on consent and do we have a
Minority Report on that yeah no it's not
Report there is yes representative
jerius I I'm happy to write it unless
someone else would like to I'm willing
okay so representative jerius will will
write a Minority Report uh Christina how
do I how do I do that yeah Christina
week June
11 you're still you're still
muted I apologize um let me get back to
you on that let me just double check uh
to make sure that I had the exact date
um but I will definitely uh get back to
you in just a
moment how do you even submit it yeah
I'll let you know I'll let you know who
to submit I I'll let you know who to
submit it to when she when she gives me
a time frame um I'll let you know who
we're gonna submit it to uh Christina I
is it going to be submitted to you do
you know uh it actually um it should be
submitted let me see you you can submit
it to me that will be fine um and then
we need this for the calendar so
probably by tomorrow um you can actually
submit it to H Karen or Heather actually
would be
fine that a Vari alter ought to
to to whom can can someone email me an
email address to send yes I will
absolutely do that for you thank you
you're
welcome okay very good uh Senate Bill
295 open the executive uh session and
recognize representative
uh digs representative Diggs thank you
thank you thank you Mr chair I and
enthusiastically make the motion that
Senate Bill 295 ought to
pass is there a
second representative
Gman so representative
Diggs by representative
Gman
discussionary see and know this see and
know
discussion representative
camarado thank you um I just want to say
that
I I think the intention of the bill is
excellent I just can't bring myself to
vote in favor of it um with what the
Attorney General's office shared with us
if that got resolved under some sort of
feedback or an amendment
then I would be in favor of it but the
way it stands I cannot support
it okay any further
discussion seeing none uh when the
Clark's ready if she could call the role
on Senate Bill 295 ought to
pass representative Baran yes
representative Mulligan definitely yes
representative Connors is a yes
representative coron yes representative
French represent can you give a thumbs
Fred yes I'm sorry not it whatever thums
go ahead representative grman yes
representative LC yes representative
patrino yeses representative Weber yes
representative
wiir yes representative D
Simone yes representative rice yes
representative
horn yes Representative
camarota no representative
Fowler
yes representative
juus yes representative
yella no
reprentative
pan
yes chairman long
yes 18 yay 2
nay very good uh we'll put this on a
regular calendar also I because there
was a there was an FN that she said
there wasn't um but it was an FN so um
do so it cannot go on consent correct oh
God no it can't go on consent yeah no
we'll put on a regular yeah yeah have a
Minority Report not doing that
again uh actually representative Yeller
or camar you want to do a Minority
Report representative Camara will do a
Minority
Report and what is your alternative
camarota interim study
maybe let's talk about that interm study
better than
I I think I think you should go with
interm
study that's my opinion well I need a
little am I unmuted I am um because it's
the end of the session what is the best
thing to do so that we can revisit it
that it's not going to be Revisited but
I would take the chair's recommendation
whether it's a interm study will it come
back no no well not this year
minority no nothing correct there'll be
a report in November that you'll have to
uh
Supply um so yeah that the clerk just
needs to know what your motion be
interim study I will do interim study
very
good is that it uh representative coners
that's it I'm all set so we're good hey
I want to thank everybody this was a
long day this was a high
day I want to thank we we have all the
members that are still here and that's
awesome representative Diggs yes thank
you Christina are you still yes ma'am um
would you also send me the um kind of
outline of what we need to do to write
our reports sure I'm happy to do that
for you right thank you so much okay and
then representative horn has his hand up
go
ahead uh Mr chairman so you've shared
with us that all of these house build
that we've work on have gone over to the
Senate through crossover which means the
Senate bills have come the same way can
you share with us um if it's your
intention to hold public hearings on all
of the Senate bills that their version
of child La has sent us so being the
chairman of Children and Family Law
that's all my all I'm responsible for
and all my decisions are when we're in
this committee uh leadership and um the
clerk's office
and both leaderships uh
decide how they're going to move forward
with these Senate bills I I haven't
heard of another hearing for us so can I
ask you if your preference is then that
we would be hearing having public
hearings on all of the legislation at
the Senate is sending it considering
that um it's what we were elected to do
if if it would be doable I'd be amable
to that absolutely thank you Mr chairman
I appreciate your uh conversation okay
very good thank you everybody uh
Christina are we all set you are all set
Christina congratulations Christina am I
scanning or am I scanning them to Paul
um you would scan them to Paul and to uh
Heather okay thank you much you're
welcome thank you so Christina you're
gonna give me an email to I am I'm GNA
send it in just a moment thank you could
you could you send one to me as well